[Musique]
Xavier Fontanet bonsoir bonsoir nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle surview nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement bon ben écoutez
d'abord merci de m'inviter hein écoutez
donc je je suis de provincial je suis P
de père Savoya et de mère bretonne et
donc c'est des familles qui ont vécu
toute leur vie en province donc en fait
j'ai j'habite Paris mais c'est des
racines sont assez sont assez anciennes
et sont très très très provinciales donc
je suis donc marié depuis 55 ans j'ai
trois filles et SEP petits enfants alors
côté éducation he je vous dis tout ça ça
pourra vous intéresser donc en fait je
suis un fils deogèse j'aiétaédqué par
les jésuites j'ai fait après les l'école
saint-jeviève préparatoire grandes
écoles j'étais au pont donc je suis jur
des ponts après donc j'ai voulu sortir
de France et j'étais aux étatsudis au
MIT donc j'ai j'ai un master du MIT et
puis après donc j'ai commencé tout de
suite ma carrière professionnel après un
service militaire j'étais donc je suis
rentré au Boston goldsy group euh donc
qui est un cabinet de conseil qui a
inventé le concept de stratégie
d'entreprise donc je pense que ça va
être un un beau sujet et et donc j'ai eu
la chance d'ailleurs de d'être embauché
par le président le fondateur Bruce
Anderson donc j'ai travaillé pendant 7
ans 8 ans au BCG puis après je suis
parti essentiellement chez des clients
donc j'ai voulu avoir une expérience de
province dans une PME donc j'ai passé 6
ans chez le chantier Beneto donc c'était
à l'époque une toute petite boîte je les
ai connu à 6 millions 6 millions d'euros
de chis d'affaires ils sont à 2
milliards aujourd'hui après on est resté
à Saint-Giles mais il y avait pas
d'école et donc j'ai pas pu me séparer
de mes trois filles l'idée de les mettre
en pension ça allait pas donc on est
rentré à Paris et puis donc là j'ai
passé 6 ans dans un métier très
différent qui sont les cantines EUR rest
qui était un des leaders de la
restauration collective donc je suis
passé de l'industrie au au service qui
est très différent et puis euh bon on
pourra discuter de tout ça j'ai eu des
des accords stratégiques avec le conseil
et j'ai collé maadème sur une décision
qu'ils ont prise du coup là je me suis
retrouvé sans job et j'ai rejoint le
groupe Essilor encore une fois tout à
fait par hasard mais le groupe ilor av
été le premier client du BCG et j'avais
eu la chance de travailler dans les
études dont je connaissais tout le monde
et là j'ai passé 20 20 23 ans comme DG
puis PDG des Silor voilà un petit peu ma
carrière alors si vous voulez avoir
j'ouvre toutous des pistes c'est pas
pour crâner mais donc j'étais
administrateur de de de de L'Oréal de
schneeder de de Crédit Agricole et de la
Bpi en fait du FSI qui était l'ANC de la
BPI j'étais dans l'émission pebro et
ataliie donc ça ça pourra vous amuser et
puis j' adore la voie le le ski et le
tennis voilà hein voilà moi la famille
compte beaucoup ah j'ai la chance
d'avoir des des familles au-dessus
merveilleuse voilà qui vont structurer
voilà on se fait une interview pétole ou
on se fait une interview tempête en
faites comme vous voulez le Breton est
habitué à habitué aux deux hein euh et
d'ailleurs le Savoyard connaît aussi le
mauvais temps et le beau temps c'est des
peuple assez proche hein c'est peuple
prs de la nature nature dangereuse c'est
une nature qui qui peut tuer la mer
comme la montagne et puis en fait c'est
des natures difficilees la mer ne
nourrit pas toujours les gens donc on a
été habitué quand même à à faire
attention au Cho on va essayer de pas
vous tuer ce soir voilà vousir mais on
est habitué à résister aussi donc c'est
vrai il faut apprendre à résister
puisque le monde est à la fois
magnifique mais dangereux donc il faut
il faut avoir les de ce soir on va
parler de stratégie de géostratégie de
géopolitique de renseignement
d'industrie de jeux vidéo et de
gamification de la stratégie et comment
détecter des bons talents des nouveaux
talents comment détecter des talents qui
pensent en dehors de la boîte ou bien
sûr
Xavier qu'est-ce que c'est une bonne
stratégie comment on fait une bonne
stratégie qui est à la tête d'une bonne
stratégie comment ça se prépare une
stratégie comment on fait de
l'anticipation comment on devient
proactif et surtout quand on est
analyste stratège comment on peut se
faire écouter par ce censé prendre des
décisions voilà B écoutez merci beaucoup
de la question donc éidment c'est
question pour moi qui est une question
fondamentale d'abord on va définir la
stratégie hein alors moi ma spécialité
c'est quand même la stratégie
d'entreprise mais j'ai évidemment
énormément étudié les stratégies
militaires parce que la guerre c'est pas
du tout comme l'entreprise ceci dit le
savoir-faire militaire il sert
énormément à l'entreprise alors clos
j'ai tout tout lu surtout ce qui
m'intéressait c'est les gros débats
qu'il y avait entre entre Napoléon et
closwitz donc ça on va y venir parce que
c'est il y a un élément très important
rajouter qui est la stratégie et
l'exécution hein les deux sont
complètement liés alors qu'est-ce que la
stratégie ben la stratégie sur en terme
d'entreprise c'est l'allocation des
ressources humaines et financière donc
j'insiste beaucoup sur les deux c'est
l'argent et les personnes hein
l'allocation contre des gens
intelligents hein qu'est-ce qui fait que
euh la la stratégie c'est intéressante
c'est que vous prenez une décision mais
vous savez la valeur de la décision
uniquement après que le concurent qui
réagit à votre décision a pris sa
décision elle va en général en sens
inverse de la vôre et c'est uniquement
donc la stratégie c'est apprendre à
décider en tenant compte de ce que font
les autres et les créents stratèges
arrivent à rentrer dans la tête des
concurrents ils arrivent à deviner les
concurrents ils sont capables de faire
des contrepieds donc il y a donc la
stratégie c'est absolument
extraordinaire parce que il y a un côté
technique que je vais pouvoir décrire
dans le casadre de l'entreprise et il y
a un côté psychologique qui est
gigantesque et culturel puisque tout le
monde sait que derrière alexand se
profile Aristote et donc moi je pousse
beaucoup mes élèves puisque je suis
devenu prof de stratégie en tant que
retraité je pousse la culture générale
parce que quand vraiment on veut un bon
stratège il faut qu'il soit habité
d'histoire et de philo hein donc la
stratégie c'est un un un terrain
absolument splendide dans l'entreprise
il a une partie technique que je peux
vous expliquer en deux coup de Cu à pet
et puis après il y a tout un
savoir-faire et il y a l'expérience qui
joue hein donc voilà le voilà un peu ce
qui la stratégie alors si vous voulez je
peux peut-être donner j'ai une chance
exceptionnelle si vous voulez euh
d'abord j'étais j'avais choisi quand
j'étais rentré en France euh donc
j'avais déjà deux petits enfants il
fallait trouver un job donc j'avais
trouvé un job chez crusevoir et puis la
veille du laaville j rentré lundi matin
la veille un copain qui m'appelle qui me
disait Xavier qu'est-ce que tu fais tu
rentres dans cette boîte c'est une très
belle boîte hein mais il me dit Xavier
écout demain tu viens au BCG il y a
Bruce Anderson qui est au bureau bon
alors pour un fontaner qui a promis
d'arriver lundi matin dira son employeur
j'arrive mardi c'était un véritable
drame mais j'ai pris la décision de
repousser et je suis arrivé donc dans
les bureaux du BCG alors c'était dans
les années 73 Boston Consulting Group
hein donc c'est un le le fond le
vraiment c'est la société qui a installé
la stratégie d'entreprise et je tombe
donc sur un bureau je pensais trouver un
beau bureau de consultant magnifique et
non c'était un petit bureau une pièce
rue de Monceau bon et avec plein de
caisses et j'arrive là euh et puis on me
dit bah écoutez il y a Bruce Anderson
qui est là il avait rendez-vous avec
ambroiseerou je sais pas si ça vous dit
quelque chose Brisou c'était le grand
patron de la CGE qui était la plus
grosse boîte de l'époque annulé euh bah
Xavier tu déjeunes avec Bruce bon et moi
je me trouve devant ce monsieur très
impressionnant ancien PDG de westing
House donc voyz c'était plus grosse
boîte américaine qui avait démarré BCG à
sa retraite hein il y avait 60 saintberg
à l'époque et il déjeune avec moi tout
simplement et alors le coup de théâtre
c'est que on commencer à discuter donc
moi je sortais du MTI donc j'avais tous
mes savoir-faireire de cour d'offre et
de demande et lui avait inventé la cour
expérience on discute et al le coup de
théâtre on était dans un bistr je me
rappelle encore toute ma vie on avait
une petite table ronde il avait une
soupe il renverse la soupe sur son
costard alors il fait ce geste là et je
dis monsieur Anderson par pitié allez
dans votre hôtel et il me dit donc
Xavier je préfère discuter avec vous
alors là je me dis là mon destin change
et donc je rentre au BCG voilà et alors
on on se battait sur une des pierres
angulaires de la stratégie qui est le
concept de cour d'expérience c'est
l'idée que plus vous avez vous améliorez
votre métier mieux vous le vous le
pratiquez et vous avez donc un avantage
concurrentiel dès que vous devenez
leader dans votre métier donc il avait
inventé évidemment la valeur de la part
de marché donc ça c'était la première
pierre angulaire et la deuxième pierre
angulaire qu'ils ont inventé c'est en
finance c'est le concept alors c'est un
peu compliqué mais c'est en gros il
relie la finance à la stratégie parce
que vous avez une règle qui est très
importante c'est que le le chi d'affair
est proportionnel au capitaux et donc si
vous voulez croître bah faut du bénéfice
qu'on réinvestit si vous tirez de
l'argent d'une entreprise vous la
freinez si vous injectez de l'argent
vous l'accélérez et donc la finance peut
devenir l'ami de la stratégie puisque
évidemment le but de la stratégie c'est
d'être leader donc descendre la cour
d'expérience et croîre plus vite et la
finance c'est la c'est la technique qui
vous permet de d'accélérer une boîte ou
la freiner et tout ça et donc c'est la
combinaison ces deux savoir-faire qui
fait que vraiment le BCG a pris une
place énorme et c'est devenu une des
plus grosses boîes de conseil du monde
aujourd'hui voilà quelle était ma
question comment quelle était ma
question qu'est-ce que la stratégie
comment on l'a fait le travail
préparatoire alors voilà et quand on se
se retrouve avec un chef voilà qui ne
sa'est pas chefer et qui veut simplement
prolonger les courbes de sa propre
carrière ah oui mais alors là justement
alors ou là là alors là la grande j'ai
envie de vous répondre la chose c'est
que il faut choisir ses chefs le grand
conseil que je donne à tout le monde
vous savez vous choisissez pas une boîte
vous choisissez les chefs et toute ma
vie si vous VZ quand j'ai embauché des
gens je dis je me disais toujours bon on
est dans un drame absolu on va être
obligé d'aller vitere dans la jungle
hein on peut partir qu' 10 il vient avec
nous ou pas he et donc on a besoin de
Jean gourdi et donc si le chef moi je
préfère avoir un bon chef dans une
situation dramatique une petite enprise
qu'un mauvais chef dans une grosse boîte
hein donc moi j'ai toujours choisi les
chefs et je conseille à tout le monde de
choisir les chefs parce que c'est les
chefs qui vous forment hein et donc moi
j'ai rencontré Bruce Anderson je me suis
rendu compte qu'il allait me tirer on
parlera de Benetto benam rou est un vrai
génie quand j'ai vu quand j'ai vu V
madame rou à l'œuve j'ai travaillé pour
elle comme consultant c'est quelqu'un de
génial on va accrocher le petit cheval
le petit chariot fontaner au cheval de
Madame rou voyez et j'ai toujours et
Silor est évidemment une boîte
phénoménale donc dès qu'ils m'ont
proposé de les
rejoindre je suis tout de suite donc
j'ai toujours choisi si vous voulez les
les qualités des gens et les situations
concurrentielles donc moi j'ai jamais eu
de chef le seul cas qui m''est arrivé
d'un chef qui me plaisait pas ça a pas
duré longtemps je me suis taillé hein
ben j'ai commencé à pas être d'accord
avec lui puis j'ai dit écouté si c'est
pas ça je démissionne et bon et je suis
parti parce qu'il me plaisait pas donc
là c'est le conseil que je donne c'est
il faut travailler avec des gens de
qualité et moi j'ai toujours préféré des
situations même difficiles quand je suis
rentré chez Benetto C hyper risqué mais
on partais avec des gens Monsieur Madame
rou étaaient des gens exceptionnels
quand j'étais consultant tout le monde
me disait d' il faut aller chez min ou
bousaline quand j'ai vu Bruce Anderson
son bureau était 100 fois plus petit
mais on dit ce type là est génial on va
avec lui donc ça c'est conseil que je
donne aux jeunes hein alors ça ça veut
dire un truc très important c'est la
notion de PIF dans la stratégie il y a
pas uniquement des savoir-faire il y a
aussi le côté humain et donc il faut
avoir le pif de découvrir et tout ça ça
prend hein et donc le donc vous voyez la
stratégie c'est un mélange très complet
alors après qu'est-ce que la stratégie i
je ne peux faire une stratégie que en
plongeant dans le concret on peut pas
faire des stratégies en général il faut
tomber dans une boîte commencer à vivre
avec elle euh calculer les marchés les
concurrents euh et il faut rentrer dans
le plus grand détail c'est meilleur
mariage ben évidemment et vous savez
tous les grands boss les bons hein on
est tous sur le terrain parce qu'on a
donner l'image fausse de patrons qui
sont dans un grand restaurant avec des
cigares et cetera c'est tous les bons
mais des très grosses boîtes hein tous
les bons ils sont tous sur le terrain je
sa pas citer trop de noms mais voyz mon
Jun sousagon de Loréal c'est des boîtes
gigantesques mais ils sont tous sur le
terrain quand vous discutez avec eux
toutes les idées ils les ont eu sur les
terrain ils les ont pas eu au siège moi
j'ai très habit de de franc gribou tout
le temps sur le terrain hein et on était
tous en fait tous tous sur le terrain on
a tous été dans le monde entier alors on
se voit dans les avions effectivement ça
crée une communauté mais on est tous sur
le terrain et on partage les problèmes
qu'on rencontre sur le terrain donc mais
il faut vraiment aller sur le terrain
après il y a tout le choix de l'équipe
l'équipe c'est quoi c'est vos sondes
c'est vos antennes c'est vos yeux vos
oreilles ben il y a tout le choix de
l'équipe alors si dans une équipe vous
avez en général quand vous avez un
métier il y a toujours une partie
production une partie distribution une
partie RD donc il faut avoir des gens
qui vous dirigent les RD des gens qui
dirigent la production tout ça c'est
assez différent il faut des financiers
des juristes et donc vous créez une
petite équipe qui est un comité de
direction alors moi j'ai toujours été
extrêmement soigneux dans le choix des
gens qu'on fait rentrer dans l'équipe
c'est une belle équipe alors une belle
équipe si vous voulez pour moi le truc
est très simple c'est qu'il faut une
grande stratégie qu'est-ce qui unifie
une équipe c'est quoi c'est une grande
stratégie hein et surtout pour les
Français les Français sont des gens
intelligents mais si on leur raconte pas
le si on leur dit pas tout il viennent
désobéissants ils sont impossibles à
gérer et donc la grande moi j'ai
toujours eu utiliser la la stratégie
comme moyen de fédérer c'est pas moi
forcément qui la faisait parce qu'on la
construisait ensemble donc je formais à
la stratégie et on la construisz
ensemble et à ce moment-là vous avez les
gens bien vous les avez puis après il y
a le climat de confiance il faut créer
un climat de confiance ça c'est un
mystère et un miracle et euh quand vous
avez une bonne stratégie et un climat de
confiance on peut emmener les gens au
bout du monde et moi j'ai eu la chance
toutes les boîtes où j'ai travaillé tout
le temps démaré petit et ils sont tous
devenus leader mondiaux tous pourquoi
parce qu'il y avait une bonne stratégie
et qu' avait on a réussi à créer une
bonne ambiance et ça on emmène les gens
au bout du monde pour la stratégie pour
la construire vous avez des analystes
vous avez des sociétés privées vous avez
des gens de la maison c'est quel type de
profil comment il sentent alors je vais
vous dire le truc très simple la tech
anti la technique Fontan est très simple
c'est que je étais depuis le début profe
de stratégie si vous voulez j'ai
toujours utilisé ce savoirfire j'ai
hérité grâce au BCG d'un d'une
compréhension complète de la stratégie
d'entreprise qui avait 50 ans d'avant
sur tout le monde donc j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir grâce à cette soupe finalement
qui est tombée sur le pantalon d'être
dans les T premiers à bon et au BCG
c'est un de ceux qui a quitté le BCG
parce qu'en général les gens restaient
et j'ai du terrain j'ai 40 ans de
terrain donc j'ai pratiqué dans les
toutes petites boîtes qui étaient Beneto
dans les boîtes de de service reste et
dans des boîtes qui sont devenu
gigantesques puisque bonoria c'est
devenu la taille de Total aujourd'hui ça
capitalise la valeur totale on est sur
des vrais vrais vrais sujets très lourds
et j'ai eu la chance et moi j'ai connu
Beneto j'ai connu
Silor tout petit j'ai connu
Silor a 10 million d'euros de Chi
d'affaires et sa sa capitalise 130
milliards alors je dis pas le chiffre
pour crâner mais parce que voilà ce que
j'ai vu et ça c'est des bonnes
stratégies c'est quand vous avez une
très bonne stratégie on arrive où qu'on
soit au leadership mondial et moi ce que
j'ai au fond ce que j'essaie d'expliquer
c'est que une fois que vous avez
savoir-faire alors la question sur les
équipes il vous formez tout le monde
comprenez une fois que le patron de la
recherche a compris ce que c'est que la
stratégie quand les commerciaux ont
compris quand les gars de production ont
compris là à ce moment-là vous créez une
espèce de système extraordinaire où tous
ensemble vous trouvez et alors la
recherche d'information parce que je
sais que c'est ça que quand vous vous
formez la stratégie on sait que vous
dépendez de l'extérieur donc il faut
info quand vous avez formé toutes les
équipes à la stratégie naturellement ils
vont chercher l'info un vendeur un
vendeur il a toute l'info comprenez un
type un acheteur il va acheter les
matières premières mais la personne qui
vend la chère première il vont au
concurrent donc si l'acheteur est malin
il apprend tout voyez et donc moi-ême
j'allais sur le stock market pour vendre
les Silor mais le nos concurrents Aya
éta côté donc quand je faisais rocho il
y avait 50 % des Silor mais j'en
apprenais Roya parce que l'investisseur
des Silor avait et avait et donc moi
j'ai construit des systèmes dans lequel
l'information c'est tout le monde qui
amenait l'information hein et parce qu'à
ce moment-là c'est très puissant parce
que vous faites qu'à comprendre à chacun
que on dépend l'extérieur on dépend du
concurrent on dépend du client voyez
donc moi j'ai jamais eu j'ai jamais eu
besoin de de grands spécialistes de la
stratégie moi j'ai formé les gens et en
même on était meilleur al je vais vous
dire un truc c'est que quand la boîte
devient mondial on a des problèmes très
spéciaux et qui sont qui sont
spécifiques d'un leader mondial et moi
c'était des c'était mes collègues leader
mondiaux du 440 parce qu' a beaucoup
plus qu'on croit en France mais c'était
tous mes collègues de Schneider de d'Air
Liquide de Loréal qui étaient eux aussi
leaders mondiaux on avait tous des
problèmes de leaders mondiaux qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on fait un déjeuner un petit
déjeuner un petit coup de fil et puis à
ce moment on se passe les tuyaux on sait
il me dit Xavier j'ai un problème
qu'est-ce que tu fais moi j'en avais un
de qu'est-ce que tu ferais de C et donc
on avait un petit réseau entre nous où
on se soutenait voyez et et donc c'est
comme ça que c'est venu donc j'ai pas eu
on n pas eu besoin de s'occuper de
d'avoir des grands spécialistes euh et
euh al par contre il faut une grande
culture faut s'intért par exemple en
Chine ben je me suis payé tous les tous
les bouquins de philo euh sur la Chine
j'ai lu toutes les tous les Sunzu toutes
les histoires de la Chine même chose
avec le Japon même chose avec la Corée
parce qu'à ce moment-là vous avez besoin
de de comprendre la le pays et donc
c'est de la c'est de la culture on
rajoute de la culture de l'histoire
voyez il faut apprendre l'histoire donc
je me suis payé toute l'histoire
chinoise pour comprendre comment ça
marchait et à ce moment-là on discute
beaucoup mieux on est dans le marché
voyez donc c'est c'est infini là alors
après il y a des grands bouquins de
stratégie à lire hein alors si al je
fais si vous voulez le le le premier
bouquin que je conseille de lire c'est
gardez-le donnez-le puis parce que à la
fin je vous demanderai trois bouquins
vous connaissez le ah bah oui oui
effectivement ben je voudrais ça à la
fin d'ailleurs vous avez lu vous avez vu
quel type d'interview chez nous comment
vous avez ah ben moi le premier que j'ai
vu le premier que j'ai vu c'est j'étais
content qu'on m' invité c'est le gars
des DF je sais pas comment ça arrivé
c'est arrivé par hasard et après donc
j'en ai vu beaucoup fois que j'ai vu je
descends la liste alors vous avez invité
des il y a des militaires il y a
l'écologie Jean évidemment g de droite
des gens de gauche ouais j'ai vu un peu
tout le monde alors entre nous ils sont
pas tous du même niveau par charité
chrétienne je dirais pas il y en a qui
sont nuls mais quand ils sont nuls on
sent très bien parce que vous vous
ennuyez et puis j'en prenais un vais
parce que j'allais j'allais en Bretagne
avec mon épouse donc on a dit tiens non
j'allais à l'Î comment on savait que je
passais j'ai regardé puis je suis tombé
sur un truc alors là il est complètement
nul quoi puis par contre après des très
bons tous les gars du renseignement donc
c'est des des trucs qui sont excellents
et alors vous sais ce qui se passe c'est
que quand on en a un très bon ben on
l'envoie au copains onz on va sur
Youtube P on met clique et puis on
l'envoie aux copain tu vas voir et
cetera donc je pense que votre par
exemple la gornerie ChAD des la qualité
mais votre truc il peut aller loin vous
êtes trop magnanime avec moi vous êtes
trop magnanim non c'est un peu de euh en
plus on a quelques noms en commun sur
certains dossier oui non mais bien sûr
bien sûr ben comme vous tapez dans vous
tapez quand même dans de du dans dans du
du haut niveau du haut niveau du haut
niveau les les les grands les grands
fauves se
reconnaissent il faut avancer en pâqu il
faut avancer ensemble on est des
entreprise notre équipe doit avancer en
pâack voilà pâack de loup meut de Lyon
euh
je rebondis sur votre anecdote de petit
déj de chef d'entreprise de haut niveau
petit dîner ou petit déjeuner non c'est
petit c'est petits déj petit déj c'est
les petits déj avant boutané oui av
avancer en pâqu est-ce que dans ces
petits déj des fois il y a nos services
de renseignement d'intelligence
économique ou de renseignement tout
court qui vous appelle en disant voilà
ce serait bien que nos chefs
d'entreprise nos pointes de diamant
avancent en pack parce que on a certains
États qui viennent nous menacer il faut
résister ensemble alors ça on le fait
assez peu on demande des avis sur ce
qu'il pense de tel ou tel pays on a eu
assez peu enfin moi ce qui me concerne
de renseignement sur le l'ensemble de la
de la géopolitique al je vais expliquer
quand même c'est que mon expérience
etilor est une boutique qui fait des
verrophtalmiques et donc en fait on
travaille on travaille avec des
opticiens voyez on n'est pas dans
l'énergie je pense que des gens qui sont
dans l'énergie là on touche vraiment au
cœur ur des VO de toute la géopolitique
là je comprends que pouyanet là il a
besoin nous dans l'optique c'est
vraiment il faut qu'il s'entraîne
avantir peut-être je dire pan mais c'est
Luc rmont mais voz par exemple quand
vous avez invité les gens des DF sblim
le patron desdf ouif Chine oui Mach bon
alors voilà on voit qu'ils sont eux
complètement imprégnés de grandes
stratégie mondiale moi je dois dire que
faut que je reste à mon à mon niveau
l'optique c'est un métier qui est ext
prèrement mondialisé je pense que Silor
est la boîte la plus mondiale du 440
puisque quand je suis parti le chiffre
d'affaires France ça devait être de
l'ordre de 5 ou 6 % 94 en dehors donc on
devit être la boîte du 440 de loin la
plus mondialisée mais on est dans des
petits métiers voyez on n pas on est en
rapport avec le gouvernement parce que
c'est un produit médical donc il faut
connaître les gouvernements parce qu'il
faut faire accepter ces produits hein
qu'on ait le droit de vendre mais on est
on dépend pas des gros des gros chocs
géostratégiques donc là de mon côté vous
ver non les les les les problèmes que
j'avais souvent c'était des choix de
people quand on choisit les gens des
doutes voyez comment est-ce qu'on voilà
he qu'est-ce que tu faire à ma place
ouais c'est pas aller chercher les gens
mais c'est tout des doutes j'ai deux
trucs de quel côté je vais j'aimerais
ton avis voyez des doutes dans quel sens
dans le dout par exemple la la boîte
d'optique tiens bah celui-là pose
beaucoup de questions travailleraitt-il
pour une puissance étrangère va-t-il
nouser n al on a eu ça c'est plus des
concurrents plutôt des concurrents qui
envoient des gens travailler pour nous
c'est plus le concurrent qui envoie du
monde hein que des puissances étrangères
qui veulent avoir les parce que nous si
vous voulez on aurait pu avoir il se
trouvait que on a eu vraiment un
leadership mondial au début qui était
pas du tout avancé mais la boîte elle a
gagné si vous voulez par des nouveaux
produits révolutionnaires les vers
organiques donc c'est le ver plastique
qui remplace le verre minéral c'est
exactement le moteur électrique cont le
moteur diesel on était des Tesla bon et
puis après il y a eu toute l'invention
des vers progressifs qui a remplacé les
bifocau c'est une 2ème puis la trisème
qu'on a eu c'est les vers
photochromiques qui remplace les ver
solaires donc ilor c'est un peu une
boîte comme Apple et c'est des profess
ce sont des inventions très propres à
l'industrie donc on n' pas eu trop de
grands méchants qui essayent de savoir
des on n pas eu trop ça et alors premier
sur les risques cyber de vous faire ah
oui alors ça il y avait des risquees
cyber donc là on avait un patron
d'informatique absolument génial et on
avait des jeunes très très fort aussi on
avait des on avait des des des jeunes gu
qui étaient assez incroyables je dois
dire que le seul risque très lourd qu'on
a eu c'était en 2000 le passage à l'an
2000 on a eu très peur parce qu'on était
dans tous les pays et donc on avait peur
d'un crash hein après il y a eu des
attaques mais à mon niveau il y a jamais
eu alors je suis parti il y a 12 ans
hein donc je je sais que le truc est
beaucoup plus grave aujourd'hui j'ai pas
eu de trop de ces histoires de risque
cyber je vous mets dans un cas concret
vous êtes patron d'une grande boîte
est-ce que nos institution censé avoir
le nez des oreilles des yeux partout
pour prendre la température et protéger
nos business vous Dirz par contre vous
dirait par exemple bon ton usine qui se
trouve de l'autre côté de la
Méditerranée on commence à s'inquiéter
parce que il y a des troubles sociaux
basés sur une défiance du au prix de
l'énergie donc au prix de la nourriture
donc ça risque de de faire des troubles
sociaux tu risques de te faire avoir
prends prends des mesures proactives ou
autre question par exemple votre votre
grand business c'est dépendant de tel
type de matière première ou du prix de
l'énergie est-ce que vous avez un
contact avec nos grands prospectivistes
nos grands stratège qui vous font
remonter par exemple attention on risque
d'avoir un problème avec notre principal
fournisseur d'énergie attention le
président de la République a décidé de
prendre ce cas ce cap donc votre
stratégie risque d'être impacté en terme
de vente en terme de collatéral damage
en terme d'impôt de taxes douanière et
et j'en passe h oui al là je vois très
bien votre question donc effectivement
on eu des contacts très polis avec
toutes les avec avec les ministères mais
il faut savoir que faut comprendre que
nos boîtes on est tous beaucoup plus
mondialisés que nos gouvernements je le
dis ça en toute humilité mais voyez par
exemple nous on s'est très vite rendu
compte que le l'environnement français
était était trop coûteux et donc si moi
j'ai vécu les premières délocalisations
des Silor moi j'ai vécu quand j'étais au
BCG en 1973 13 ça ne me rajeunit pas ça
fait 50 ans on s'était déjà rendu compte
qu'il n'était pas possible de conquérir
le monde à partir de nos usines dionèse
fut-elle complètement automatisée et
donc on a commencé à mettre des usines
aux États-Unis moi j'étais sur une étude
des usines Silor États-Unis en 1973
première étude BCG quand je rentre voyez
hein et et et puis alors après quand on
est rentré chez Silor on on s'est bien
rendu compte aussi que on a été attaqué
par notre concurrent japonais qui avait
des US en Thaïlande et qui attaquait
l'Europe avec des prix thaïlandais on a
tout de suite monté une usine aux
Philippines pour pouvoir matcher le truc
et ça alors là je mets déjà c'est dans
les années c'était aussi dans les années
75 voyez donc on a complètement en Chine
on s'est très très bien rendu compte que
la seule façon d'attaquer la Chine
c'était de mettre une usine à shanghï
mais je peux le dire honnêtement on a
discuté on peut le dire maintenant mais
les Chinois dirent on a dit écoutez on
est prêt à vous mettre une très grosse
usine à shanghï alors à l'époque c'était
il y a longtemps C en 94
ça fait 30 ans hein moi j'étais jeune
PDG à l'époque et on a dit aux Chinois
écoutez on est prêt mais alors c'est pas
compliqué l'usine on va la charger avec
des volumes américains donc on ferme une
usine américaine qui n'est plus très
compétitive on va charger l'usine
shanghïaise avec tout le volume
américain vous fait un gigantesque
cadeau d'accord bon en échange je vous
demande des droits de douane pendant 15
ans à 40 % pour pas qu'on se fasse
attaquer par une usine du Laos à choisir
ben les Chinois marché donc vous rendez
compte qu'on avait on est déjà il y a il
y a 30 ans on discutait avec les Chinois
comme Gal de Gaulle ou comme les
Européens il devrait dire attendez
attendez BYD moi je veux bien que vous
mettiez des usines que vous vendiez en
Europe mais attendez je veux bien mais
vous mettez une usine en Europe d'accord
sinon on voit pas et moi je veux que les
batteries de votre fabricant de batterie
auprès duquel
B que ces batteries là stantis puissent
les acheter au même prix alors vous nous
permettez vous nous mettez une usine en
Europe et stellantis a accès au prix des
batteries chinoises au même prix on est
d'accord on a fait ça mais nous on fait
ça depuis 30 ans voyez et donc je pense
queil faut que les l'état voit que en
matière industrielle il y a des très
belles boîtes françaises les chenz d'air
toutes ces boîtes là qui sont totalement
mondialisées on a sans crâner on baigne
dans ce truc là depuis 50 ans toute ma
vie j'ai baigné là-dedans hein et donc
là je trouve qu'on a entre nous on a un
peu d'avance
mais ça alors par contre c'est très
attendez j'ai un énorme respect pour les
affaires étrangères les affaires
étrangères grand grands ambassadeurs
avant ou après
Macron le ministère d' affffaires
étrangères après c'est la place que leur
donne Macron mais je dis que les grands
les grands les grands ambassadeurs ils
sont absolument géniaux hein et moi j'ai
eu la chance d'avoir beaucoup de les
contacter alors nous on était surtout
avec les clients donc c'est pas
l'ambassadeur qui va aider Silor à
vendre au mais on avait toujours garder
des normes de très bonnes relations
parce que en cas de pépin c'est très
utile si on commence à avir des pépins
ils sont là pour vous aider et moi j'ai
toujours trouvé que le le niveau les
ambassadeurs absolument éblouissant
absolument éblouissant et là alors après
c'est l'importance qu'on leur donne mais
à mon avis on leur donne pas
l'importance qu'il mérite surtout dans
cette période de guerre parce que c'est
on a besoin de on a besoin de diplomate
pour discuter avec l'ennemi hein et ils
ont des connaissances c'est les gens qui
ont des vocations ils ont passé tout
leur temps il faut même aller chercher
les gars qui sont à la retraite les
ambassadeurs d'ailleurs on les voit sur
les plateaux télé ils sont excellents
les militaires et les les ambassadeurs
que vous voyez à la télé ils sont
géniaux donc il y a quand même il y a il
y a une qualité dans dans cette fonction
publique qui est quand même grande hein
il faut le dire donc quand vous avez des
petits problèmes à l'étranger donc vousz
vous allez voir le le l'ambassade ou le
Kor on a eu assez peu on estce vous avez
eu on a eu des procès don honnêtement on
a eu assez peu de on a eu assez peu de
de difficulté parce que je veux dire on
est dans un un métier qui était un
métier plus facile vous voyez qui était
moins un métier Dang encore que la vue
soit fondamentale mais la BU c'est
fondamentale mais on n pas eu de on n
pas eu de problème en Chine si vous
voulez ils nous ont ouvert parce que
qu'est-ce qu'on faisait aux Chinois en
leur disait on va vous donner la vue or
ils sont tous m comme des taupes donc
nous c'était fabuleux vous comprenez
quand moi je me rappelle toute ma vie on
allait au début quand on a commencé moi
je me rappelle on a commencé en 90 donc
c'était après danoping bah au début
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on se promène à
shangï dès qu'on voit un mec qui a une
lunettes on l'appelle t as acheté tes
lunettes on va voir le peticien moi j'ai
fais ça moi-même hein et puis après on
va chez le peticien on discute le coup
où tu où tas acheté tes verres et tes
montures il donne l'adresse P on va voir
les usines vous voyez comment on a fait
on aenseignement économique on a
commencé de zéro mais moi-même je me
rappelle dans la rue on arrêtait les
gens et puis on disait ils nous emmenit
chez l'opticien vous voyez le truc et et
on a monté de zéro de 00 et alors ça
c'est on a fait ça et tout seul comme
des grands voyez et c'est toutes les
boîtes ont fait ça toutes les grandes
boîes tous les boss et c'est ce qu'il
faut dire au petit français voyez et la
création de valeur elle est là hein et
donc terrain terrain terrain terrainin
et puis après moi je je sais très bien
qu'après quand vous êtes sur le terrain
les idées stratégiques viennent quand
vous êtes sur le terrain moi je me
rappelle pari si vous commencez à me
lancer les histoires sont sont
absolument infin mais une des plus
intéressantes c'est on était en Corée
donc on est on avait une très belle
boîte en Corée al l'histoire comment
est-il arrivé c'est une autre histoire
mais on avait un gros débat avec
marketing France parce que les les les
quantités de verre qu'on trouvait en
Corée étaient énorme et le marketing
central disait non les chiffres sont
mauvais beaucoup trop gros mais
qu'est-ce qu'on avait découvert c'est la
myopie grandissante des des des des des
Chinois et des tout l'as faut savoir
qu'il y a un fléo sur toute l'Asie c'est
que les ils viennent tous trèmop et vous
savez que c'est dramatique c'est qu'un
gosse un gosse chinois alors le problème
qu'ils ont c'est qu'ils ont des bouquins
de classe trop petit donc ils regardent
trop près et ça fait grossir les yeux et
donc il y a le fléo bon et donc nous
vous rendez compte on les sauvait de ce
fléo avec des verrs en corrigeant les
verre et on a lancé le fameux verre
stellest qui est un un succès absolument
extraordinaire c'est un verre qui réduit
la miopie des enfants alors qu'est-ce
que vous voulez je vous dise à ce
moment-là alors après dans les classes
c'est pas compliqué on donne moi j'ai
fais ça moi-même parce qu'on s'amusait
comme des fous on dit écoutez on va
prendre une classe et puis on va donner
il y a 50 élèves allez on va donner cinq
lunettes bon qu'est-ce qui se passe un
an après tous ceux qui ont des lunettes
ont les meilleures notes alors qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on appelle le verre good
student et on dit aux grands-parents
vous voulez que vos enfants soi premiè
en classe acheter des vercilor voyez
truc puis après je me rappelle toute ma
vie il y a une ville qui s'appelle wing
qui est une très grosse ville dans
laquelle les gens avent pas encore de
lunettes alors par rapport à shanghï
alors on discute avec le maire on dit
mais Monsieur le Maire ils sont tous mi
V gars mais les ouvriers il voient rien
donc les qu'il vont avoir sont beaucoup
plus bas que les ouvriers de la ville
d'à côté qui ont des tout de suite le
maire dit mettez-moi un hôpital et
cetera et donc on a passé notre temps à
faire le tour de toute la Chine en
montant les villes les unes contre les
autres mettez-moi un hôpital c'est vous
avez construit un hôpital non non c'est
non c'est le le maire qui faisait
l'hôpital optique voyez après on était
des classes donc on a fait des classes
nous-mêmes on a fait des écoles est-ce
que vous avez été obligé des fois de de
je sais que ça se faisait des un peu à
l'époque de faire des pots de vin et
ensuite déclarer les pots de vins à
ber Mar JIS honnêtement on a jamais eu
on avait un produit tellement puissant
on n pas eu on a jamais eu besoin de ça
non non dans le truc après don là où ce
qu'on faisait c'est que le maire on
disait écoutez il vous faut des écoles
il vous faut des écoles des écoles
d'optique alors la technique qu'on avait
c'est que il y a pas mal d' on
transformait les bijoutier en magasin
d'optique parce qu'on montrait qu'on
faisait plus d'argent avec des lunettes
que en vendant de l'or bon à ce momentlà
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on fait on fait une
on fait une école d'optique puis après
c'est super simple parce que les les les
gens qui font de l'or ben mettre les
enfants dans l'école d'optique et et
c'est super rentable donc l'école elle
est rentable donc on a monté des réseaux
d'écolees dans toute la Chine d' ri qui
est le grand patron de la Chine je lu
fait faire un livre donc il va tout
raconter dans le détail c'est
extraordinaire tout c'est à pleuréd on
s'est amusé comme des fous et donc les
écoles étaient hyper rentables et donc
et après alors là où il y avait un truc
c'est que le maire de la ville disait
c'est nous qui faisons les diplômes bon
alors on faisait des diplômes d'opticien
mais on était chapoté par le maire de la
ville mais le maire avait tellement
besoin que les gens lunette qui nous
faiser le travail donc nous la Chine
qu'on a connu c'est une Chine dans
laquelle ils étaient tous à nous aider
on a on a monté une boîte gigantesque on
a été aidé et on est parti de rien de
rien du tout de 20 et c'est une histoire
extraordinaire oui vous parliez de vue
moi je vais vous parler de cap de clé de
lecture de prisme de lecture un
dirigeant un chef d'entreprise de taille
mondial quelle est sa principale clé de
lecture quel est son cap comment il il
développe sa cl alors moi c'est très
simple he moi le truc est très clair
c'était la concurrence c'est que alors
moi c'est la grande technique du BCG
c'est que ce qui compte c'est le rapport
au concurrents donc pour moi al côté
côté business j'avais tris quatre
concurrents en fait il y avait on avait
démarré on était 10e quand j'étais
rentré au BCG en 73 et Silor était 10e
et on est devenu leader mondial parce
que on avait les produits de verre
organique et ver progressif qui étaient
les produits révolutionnaires donc on a
tiré le tapis s tous les concurrent
après on a eu deux concurrents très très
durs il y avait donc un Australien qui
s'appelait sola qui avait conquis
l'Amérique parce que quand vous regardez
la carte des géographies l'Australie
elle a la Californie et donc ils avaient
pris l'Amérique par la Californie ils
étaient devenu extrêmement puissant hein
et puis on avait Oya qui était un
concurrent japonais qui était vraiment
une des plus belles boîtes japonaises
donc on avait deux dures à cuire hein
alors évidemment moi c'était l'obsession
de connaître Oya et sola et quand je
suis arrivé chez Silor euh venant de
reste et sior avait un gros sujet c'est
qu'on avait trop de lignes de produit on
avait les vers on était dans les veres
de contact on était dans les dans les
implants intraoculaires et dans les
montures et j'ai dit àor attendez on va
pas tout pousser parce qu'on est bon en
vert mais on ne peut pas gagner les
montures verre de contact et implant
c'est les pharmaciens donc j'ai persuadé
la maison ilor d'enlever un tiers de son
chi d'affaires un/ers hein et on a dit
on met tout sur les verres parce que ce
qui se passait c'est que là l'argent que
faisait les veres partait dans les ver
de contact et donc les vers ne
poussaient pas assez vite alors que les
deux autres qui étaient spécialisés
allit plus vite que nous et j'ai dit
attendez si on fait pas ça on va se
faire dépasser moi l'obsession ça a été
la lutte contre Oya et cela et donc
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait c'est vous vous
renseignez complètement alors vous avez
Oya était une boîte japonaise magnifique
qui était dans un conglomérat et c'était
qu'il avait des vachalis et donc il y
avait des lignes de produits et le
patron du conglomérat monsieur suuk le
propriétaire de envoyait du cash donc
c'est une boîte très dangereuse pour
nous parce que ils étaient géniaux en
production et il y a en plus du cash
vous voyez bon c'est ce que je expliquis
sur la finance l'autre par contre cela
était hyper brillant mais il sétait très
endetté puis ils avaient un actionnaire
faible qui était le groupe pkinton et
donc à ce moment-là quand on a eu on a
dit on va il faut on peut pas se les
payer tous les deux ensemble il faut en
choisir un des deux et on s'est payé
d'abord cela et donc ça été l'Amérique
et donc on a fait une conquête
extraordinaire de l'Amérique donc je
raconte ça dans mes bouquins c'est
vraiment marrant et une fois qu'on a
conqui l'Amérique on avait l'Europe à ce
momentl on a commencé à se colierya on
avait de vachalis la vachalet européenne
et là on a commencé à bien le secouer
alors comme c'est une boîte hyper
géniale ils ont résisté mais on a quand
même pris un leadership mondial
incontesté dans la alors pour faire ça
on a fait deux choses on s'est marié
avec son pire ennemi au Japon donc c'est
dans la stratégie aussi tout l'art de
l'Alliance hein tout l'art de la guerre
la de la guerre et de l'Alliance hein et
donc on a réussi à se marier avec le
groupe Nikon qui était son pire
concurrent au Japon al ça c'est un coup
de génie on a réussi à gagner la
confiance de de de Nikon alors là une
fois qu'on a mis le pied au Japon dans
la vache àis on commençait à la
contrôler alors on l'a pas on on na pas
voulu trop l'abîmer parce que on aurait
déclenché un cataclysme total donc on
l'a laissé leader mais on le contrôlait
puis on s'est rendu compte qu'il était
leader au Japon en Corée parce que Corée
jaapon c'est pareil et du coup on s'est
marié avec une boîte géniale en Corée et
on a commencé vraiment à gêner et là
donc maintenant et et et donc ces boîtes
même je sais maintenant 12 ans après bah
ces boîtesl continuent à être super
rentables c'est des boîtes absolument
magnifiques qu'on a qu'on a qu'on a
qu'on a fait rentrer dans le groupeilor
et grâce à ça si vous a réussi à
contrôler c'est comme ça qu'on a créé
leadership voyez comment vous et c'est
de la stratégie ça Heinz il faut d'abord
se recentrer donc ça c'est tout le
savoir-faire de recentrer une boîte et
puis après vous avez
il faut savoir lequel vous prenez les
Oras et les cuurias HE alors après on a
décidé de taper sur cel on a réussi à
l'avir puis après vous tapez avec vos de
vachesalet donc il y a tout le
savoir-faire de stratégie c'est les
matrices BCG tout ça donc a si vous
voulez en stratégie il y a tout un
savoir-faire théorique qu'il faut avoir
et une fois que vous l'avez vous
l'appliquez partout et le savoir-faire
du BCG il est universel et intemporel
c'est que si on va regarder ce que
faisaient les Vénitiens ce que faisaient
les Hollandais bah vous tombez
exactement
sur les mêmes principes de stratégie
donc céit c'est c'est ça où le truc est
très puissant hein quel regard vous
portez sur la France sa stratégie pour
protéger ses industries sa stratégie
pour protéger son business sa stratégie
pour aider ses businessman ses
entrepreneurs pour préserver les marchés
pour aller chercher les marchés et
surtout pour défendre ses entreprises
bien sûr alors là si vous voulez c'est
un énorme sujet don j'y passe ma
retraite merci de me donner l'occasion
alors si vous voulez effectivement moi
je suis resté très longtemps sur les
stratégies de l'entreprise mais à un
moment donné vous vous rendez compte
quand même que le pays impose à à
quelque part c'est pas neutre alors je
pense si vous voulez al je viens de
tourner une émission sur BFM donc on
pourra r disccuter mais en gros là parce
qu'on m'a demandé ce que je pensais de
ça voilà donc je vais vous dire dire en
quelques Pasin non non vous l' pas eu
non parce qu'elle va sortir dans une
semaine donc c'est moi c'était ma grosse
journée parce que c'est à midi
j'aienregistraé le truc c'est la grosse
journée mais c'est formidable ça me rend
alors si vous voulez je pense qu'il y a
eu une grande période la grande période
on va prendre 100 ans d'histoire on va
partir de la guerre donc il y a eu le
plan Marshal qui a relancé toute
l'économie on a eu la 4e République
c'était l'année fouracier des 30
glorieuses donc on a connu en fait une
très grande croissance de l'économie et
euh et puis de descendre de la dette
hein puisque la France était endettée
pratiquement au au au chiffre d'affaires
à son PIB à cause de la du plan Marshal
et le bas de la dette le bas de la dette
c'est 73 et à mon avis on a un très très
gros changement en 73 ça pas été la ça
pas été la guerre du du pétrole ça pas
été la crise du pétrole c'est que de GA
les Pompidou pour qui j'ai la plus
grande admiration était donc la personne
qui les inspirait c'était JAC Ruf je
sais pas si vous connaissez ruef le plan
Armand ruef et Jacques ruef donc avait
comme idée que l'État doit pas dépasser
30 % du PIB et qu'il faut garder des
budgets en équilibre de façon à pas
surcharger les boîtes et laisser les
boîtes se démerder tout seul mais pas
les surcharger est arrivé giscar et
giscar moi je sais que c'était je
j'avais suivi le truc de très près parce
que il y avait un très grand économiste
s'appelle Stoleru je sais pas si vousz
connu et qui était donc qui était qui
était un polytechnicien qui est décédé
maintenant et qui était devenu lesgérie
de giscar et qui a défendu Kees donc
Kees c'est pas du tout pas du tout le
REF Kees vous explique que quand vous
l'État dépense de l'argent il y a un
effet multiplicateur qui fait que ça
booste l'économie et et donc avant la
première fois où vous voyez la dette
remonter et ben c'est le premier emprint
giscar et après si vous voulez gauche et
droite on gardait ke c'est que militeran
était ravi quand il a commencé à
en l'air toutes les tous les comptes
publics il était ravi de pouvoir dire il
y a ke effet multiplicateur et donc vous
avez des tas d'économistes kénésiens qui
nous arroncent dans tous les dans tous
les médias alors nous maintenant les
entrepreneurs on commence à dire
attendez on va regarder ce qui se passe
parce que la dette si vous voulez elle a
commencé en 73 quand vous regardez les
chif chiffre et là vous voyez où on en
est parce que quand vous commencez à
pousser du multiplicateur vous défendez
les les déficits publics mais déficit
public c'est c'est la part du PIP qui
grimpe la par de l'État dans qui grimpe
et elle est montée à 57 58
elle a même fliré que 60 voyez ça veut
dire que les 2 tiers de la valeur
ajoutée c'est l'état et pas l'entreprise
vous comprz alors si encore l'État était
d'une efficacité exceptionnelle mais
vous êtes d'accord bon je vous vois
sourire bon et et je crois que alors
c'est pas les fonctionnaire ils sont
remarquables c'est le système qui est
mal organisé et c'est pour ça qu'il
faudrait je trouve qu'un jour on demande
au au chefs d'entreprise d' mettre un
peu leur nez là-dedans donc ça merci de
de de pousser ces idées et alors
actuellement si vous voulez la dépense
publique elle est elle est trop cherre
alors j'ai lancé l'idée du cheval et du
jocket vous VZ pas entendu le jocket
obèse bon je vais expliquer c'est très
simple le jocket qui ralentit son cheval
voilà qui est trop lourd alors j'ai
expliqué le truc qui est extrêmement
simple c'est que quand moi j'ai l'ai vu
avec essor tous les tous les surcoups de
la sphère publique sont dans les prix de
des entreprises toute la partie sociale
c'est dans les salaires
puisqueaujourd'hui en France vous
doublez le salaire pour tenir compte de
tout de la et puis après vous avez des
tas d'impôts qu'on rajoute dans
l'entreprise et quand l'État est trop
lourd il rajoute des impôts et vous avez
les fameux impôts de production qu'on a
en France qui vous comble qu'on rajoute
à l'entreprise puis après les impôts sur
le bénéfice sont plus élevés puis par
époque il y a Desf et tout ça et donc le
cheval le problème qu'on a c'est qu'on a
un bon cheval en France simplement le
jocket est beaucoup trop lourd hein
parce que quand vous avez voyez quand
vous avez je vous expliquer les chiffres
quand vous avez la sphère publique à 57
la sphère privée est à 43 d'accord donc
la sphère publique c'est 1,32 la sphère
privée prenez un petit cochon qui est à
100 il est 100 hors taxe vous voulez
rajouter 132 il vaut 232 prenez un petit
cochon allemand il sort même
productivité il est à 100 en Allemagne
la dépense publique est 54 et pr 44 et
le privé 56 donc 44/ 56 c'est un 7 donc
le petit cochon qui vaut 100 on lui
rajoute 70 donc vous avez 230 contre 170
uniquement à cause deaffaire publique le
cochon le petit cochon français est plus
cher que le cochon allemand qu'est-ce
qui se passe hein comme l'impôt sur le
bénéfice est plus élevé en France qu'en
Allemagne non seulement il fait moins
d'argent mais en plus il peut il est
obligé d' il en garde moin alors sur 10
ans ben vous foutez les industries en
l'air n c'est ce qu'on commence à
expliquer donc le jocket obèse freine le
cheval voyez donc le tue et ben il le
tué à la fin il le tue parce que si le
cheval devient trop petit il est tué
voyez et donc ça c'est l'idée
fondamentale qu'il faut expliquer tué
par les autres bah c'est l'Allemand qui
porte un jocket plus léger il va le Prix
de l'Arc de Triomphe n'est jamais gagné
par un jocket obèse hein et donc en fait
petit à petit le cheval se fatigue alors
effectivement il court moins vite alors
je sais pas si vous savez que prenez les
PIB par tête euh en 2000 en 60 en 73 à
la mort de Pompon est-ce que vous savez
que la la France par exemple avait
pratiquement le même payb part tête que
la Suisse aujourd'hui la Suisse est à 2
et demi le SMIC à Genève vous savez
combien il est 4000 balles il est à 5000
balles alors mettons 45 100000 balles
vous rendez compte rendez compte le
pouvoir d'achat et toutes les
souffrances qu'on a c'est quoi c'est que
la France perd des par marché et croit
pas assez vite on est on avait le 7e PIB
par tête en 74 on est 28e aujourd'hui
rendez compte de la descente alors nous
les entrepreneurs qu'est-ce qu'on dit
alors nous nos boîtes elles ont explosé
bah parce qu'on s'est mondialisé donc
c'est pas les entrepreneurs qui sont
mauvais c'est que les chevaux sont trop
lourds alors il faut il faut baisser le
prix du cheval alors j'explique dans
l'émission que je fais tourner si vous
voulez le on le le cheval c'est très
simple il y a de c'est horrible à dire
mais j'ai j'ai le devoir de le dire ne
serait-ce que pour les boîtes c'est que
il y a au niveau on va il faut il faut
appeler les choses par le nom je pense
que la gauche si vous voulez avec la
retraite à 60 ans a fait un truc
complètement fou euh donc le coût on va
calculer le coût vous savez que les
déficit actuellement de la retraite
c'est de l'ORD de 70 milliards hein
alors ils sont ils sont dans les comptés
dans les comptes publics ou pas du tout
ils sont dans les comptes publics ce qui
s'est passé si vous voz c'est que le
corps disait que la perte était plus
petite mais le il y a eu des comptes
passés par le public ils ont appelé ils
ont mis des subventions qui qui font
passer pour des cotisations hein donc en
fait on plombe les comptes publics pour
équilibrer les comptes de tout ce qui
est services spéciaux VO donc le déficit
il est 70 milliards hein bon et puis la
santé est un déficite à 30 donc vous
avez 100 milliards sur les 150 milliards
qui viennent du social alors moi tous
les chefs d'entreprise qu'est-ce qu'on
dit il faut que l'État sorte du social
l'État est rentré dans le social et a
commencé à à à combler toutes les tout
le trou des caisses avec en gros la
gauche faut simplifier les choses
c'était pas du temps de giscar encore
mais c'est c'est du temps de la gauche
et et et les gouvernements de droite qui
ont suivi et là dans les 150 milliards
de pertes c'est 100 milliards le social
donc l'état peut pas tout faire et dans
tous les pays d'Europe l'Allemagne par
exemple Schredder a dit j'ai plus les
sous pour payer le régalien les socials
mon boulot c'est le régalien des merd
zizich c'était le truc et donc syndicat
et patronat mais qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
fait ils ont en 2005 ils ont tout de
suite passé la retraite à à 65 ans il la
mettent à 67 et ils ont mis un ticket
modérateur pour la santé un ticket
modérateur à 25 € et ça a tout réglé
voyez alors après on on a donc plus que
50 milliards de pertes puisque dé 150 on
AR après si vous voulez il faut remettre
de l'argent dans l'armée c'est évident
maintenant il faut 50
milillliards quoi donc faut doubler le
budget de l'armée du temps de Gaulle
l'armée était à 6 % est aujourd'hui à 2
qu'estce qui se passe aujourd'hui je
m'excuse il faut absolument aider les
Ukrainiens donc il y a maintenant une
dimension géopolitique qui rentre dans
tous les trucs il il faut évidemment
tous les sur impôts qu'on les
entreprises faut les enlever hein et
puis il faut commencer à rembourser la
dette parce que 3000 milliards de dettes
vous rendez compte on risque de dépenser
100 milliards tous les ans en 5 ans ça
fait 500 milliards il faut tout de suite
bon alors si vous mettez ça moi il faut
je dis que il faut rajouter encore 150
milliards faut peut-être les 50
milliards dans la dans l'armée il faut
les 80 milliards ça c'est les impôt de
production qu'il faut enlever faut
remettre faut rembourser la dette à
coûte 60 milliards par an donc vous
voyez on a besoin il y a 150 milliards
de trous il faut rajouter moins C 300
milliards comment on fait et comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour faire ça comment
on fait dans un climat je voulais vous
poser une une il faut pas taper sur le
micro il dit l'ingénieur du son
tu m'as coupé ma questionon fait
attendez attendez attendez le le comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour faire une
stratégie voilà avec des paramètres
qu'on a pas anticipé alors att par
exemple oui on voit les prévisions de
rentrée de TVA mais on avait pas pensé
que ça ça allait un petit peu faire
grosse tempête d'ici une semaine comment
on fait une stratégie une prospective
efficiente pointe de diamant tranché
appelez ça comme vous voulez a quand on
a des cabinets de stratégie qui ne
s'expose pas à des stress tests ou à des
choses qu'il n'avaient pas anticipé dans
leur jeu de simulation ça ça va me
permettre après de lancer un prochain
une prochaine question donc couper tout
ça alors que on s'est coupé de notre
principal marché énergétique qu'on
achète le gaz de schiste américain
quatre fois plus cher qu'on a fait de la
subordation de vote à grand coup de
subvention votez pour moi je suis le
président du pouvoir d'achat votez pour
moi je vous apporterai mon émerveilles
avec mes lunettes roses comment on fait
dans ce clima d'instabilité politique
bien sûr d'instabilité énergétique
d'instabilité en terme d'inflation sur
les matières premières bien sûr alors
attendez il a des sujets il y a tout il
y a tout le sujet énergétique je vais en
parler je vais peut-être terminer ce que
je racontais et puis après on va parler
je vous promets je parce que c'est un
truc qui me passionne là Xavier alors si
vous voulez le le le vrai sujet si vous
voulez on a parlé de Napoléon si vous
voulez il y a un moment donné je pense
que les Français sont des gens
responsables si on leur parle vraiment
sérieusement il y a un ton à trouver
c'est pas l'immédiat mais je pense que
personnellementi j'ai eu plusieurs fois
à retourner des situations très graves
dans les entreprises j'ai toujours parié
sur le C des Français et Napoléon est un
est un gars épouvantable mais assez
génial si vous voulez le le jour des la
veille des batailles importantes
qu'est-ce qu'il faisait il allait dans
les tentes il expliquait la stratégie du
lendemain et l'importance de la bataille
dans l'ensemble de la guerre à austerlis
aller voir le film na belel Gans qui est
à pleurer de beauté euh Napoléon
explique au grognard non seulement la
stratégie du lendemain mais pourquoi il
faut gagner au stlis parce que si on
gagne au CLIS la la la messe elle est
dite bon pourquoi c'est pas fait avec
l'Ukraine ça et ben c'est ce qu'il faut
faire maintenant c'est pas trop tard non
non je pense que c'est un autre sujet
qu'on pourra faire je vous dirai moi je
attendez moi je veux pas sortir non plus
de mon humble situation de retraité hein
mais on a le droit de réfléchir parce
que c'est le but de réfléchir si vous
voulez si vous voulez on pourra on
pourra parler de ce sujettique on peut
écluser les géopolitiques on peut
l'écluser mais bon vousinvitez l'an
prochain ou mais je termine mon truc si
vous voulez parce que c'est alors moi si
vous voulez Napoléon et grognard
qu'est-ce qu'il disait il disait
empereur tu nous as fait confiance tu n
tout dit tu nas expliquer les risques
que tu courrais ben fais-nous confiance
et tu nous as pris pour des grandes
personnes demain on sera au combat et
moi j'ai beaucoup étudié closwiitz svez
closwiitz c'était l'adversaire de
Napoléon et closwiitz a une grande
différence et dans les batailles
closwiitz se mettait dans un château à
25 m de la bataille et on lui amenait
les cartes et tranquillement au calme
sans le stress de la bataille closeville
disait quoi faire et à la fin de sa vie
closeville a dit il reconnaissait que
les Français étaient meilleur que les
Prussiens pourquoi parce que les les
Français s'appropriaent la stratégie
alors que les Prussiens plus nombreux et
mieux armés ne faisaent qu'obéir au chef
voyez à pleurer de beauté bon et ça
c'est le beau côté de Napoléon et je
pense qu'à un moment donné alors c'est à
est-ce que quelqu'un sera capable de le
faire il y a un moment donné comme de
Gaul ça allit le faire il faut parler au
français en parlant sérieux et moi je
pense si vous voulez que le le truc a
gagné les TR milliards si vous voulez on
a les 150 milliards de déficit plus faut
rajouter 100 milliards entre le
militaire les impôts de production et il
faut 300 milliards il y a deux façons de
les retrouver très simplement le premier
c'est la fonction publique qui n'est pas
efficace comme elle devrai puisque la
Rosière invité Jacques de la Rosière on
l' déjà invité une personne
extraordinaire extraordinaire Jacques de
la Rosière dit écoutez les Français on a
5,7 million de fonctionnaires pour pour
65 millions d'habitants les Allemands 45
pour 6 c'est 2 millions 2 millions de
trop 2 millions de trop à 70000
fonctionnaires 150 milliards hein donc
il nous faut 300 milliards moi je vous
en trouve déjà 155 avec le avec le la la
mise à niveau qui va prendre 10 ans hein
parce qu'il faut il y a tout un travail
pour remettre ça à niveau mais mise à
niveau on a avec la la retraite si vous
si vous déplacez chaque année chaque
année déplacé de la retraite en gros
c'est 20 25 milliards qu'on économise
parce qu'on verse moins de prestations
et on a plus de cotisation donc en 3
années on remet la retraite à l' par
contre faut aller à 67 ans de retraite
hein et troisièmement vous mettez un
ticket modérateur sur la santé vous
mettez tout l'équilibre donc là déjà
j'ai récupéré et l'autre truc que
personne ne raconte c'est le les 35h on
n'a jamais raconté que les 35 he c'est
une catastrophe alors c'est tellement
génial les 35 he vous cher amis vous
prenez du temps libre hein et vous
donnez du boul aux autres c'est génial
bon sauf que ça marche pas et et et ben
vous avez tout de suite vu le truc et et
on fait le calcul vous mettez 25
millions de personnes qui travaillent 4
He pas c'est 4 qu fois par mois 4 mois
11 mois le prix moyen c'est 19 € leheure
vous multipez par 2 vous perdez 200
milliards vous perdez de 2 à 220
milliards de PIB ça fait 100 milliards
de recettes donc avec les économies de
Jacques de la Rosière sur les
fonctionnaires et le passage à 40h on
retrouve la somme qui qui nous permet de
combler les trous et de refaire ce qu'il
faut pour remettre du fric dans l'armée
et ça si vous voulez je pense qu'il faut
faire rentrer la dimension maintenant
géopolitique dans les discussions il
serait temps il serait temps et à ce
moment-là dire écoutez on est en train
de jouer notre avenir parce que si on
fait les cons on sait jamais ce qui peut
se passer voyez et donc il faudrait
trouver alors merci parce que votre
émission est très importante je suis sûr
qu'elle va circuler et donc c'est des
petites c'est des petits passages qui
vont qui vont passer rem-moi
remettez-moi votre cvate droite oui
merci il faut bien ou oui d'accord mais
vous avez compris le truc donc voilà
alors maintenant je peux parlerop de
juste entre avant de passer à vous avez
compris le raisonnement et les Français
ils sont intelligents on fait quoi avec
l'évasion fiscale dans tout ça parce
qu'il paraît que ça rapporterait des
centaines de milliards ça aussi ah bah
faut faut faut taper dessus évidemment
bah si ça rajoute si on peut rajouter
avec les tricheries les tricheries sur
la carte bleue l'évasion fiscale faut
évidemment taper dessus là j'ai zéro
problème mais euh la vraie masse la
vraie masse c'est ce dont je parle c'est
le vrai les vrais sous ils sont là hein
ils sont pas il faut bien sûr le faire
mais il faut pas se faut pas alors
actuellement on fait croire qu' en
luttant qu' l'évasion fiscale et les
tricheries sur la carte bleue mais c'est
des cacahuètes tout ça les vrais sujets
c'est les masses dont je vous parle qui
sont quand même 100 milliards pour
l'évasion fiscale oui mais est-ce que
c'est vrai est-ce que les chiffres sont
vrais si vous voulez al qu'est-ce qui
fait partir les gens d'ailleurs en
évasion fiscale bah non mais le problème
c'est les problèmes de il faut être
conscient sur les des fiscalités de
plusvalue si vous voulez vous éêtes de
pays vous es à Singapour si vous es à
Singapour il y a pas de des impôts c'est
à 20 % et il y a pas de fiscalité sur
les les ventes d'actions issu stock
option donc à ce moment-là vous avez des
donc il y a énormément de cas de 440 qui
sont qui sont à Singapour si vous avez
Canada c'est pareil c'est moins il y a
quand même plus d'impôts mais c'est
beaucoup plus bas chypr la France oui
alors Chypre si on veut Malte Malte
peut-être oui oui bon mais ça c'est des
petits trucs les vrais truc Luxembourg
bien sûr Belgique donc là il faut oui
bien sûr non mais pratiquement mais on a
les impaus les plus élevés donc d non le
truc très intéressant c'est l'Italie si
vous voulez mélonie est super maline
elle est en train de faire un truc dans
lequel la fiscalité sera pas sur les
revenus mais sur la dépense et là alors
là vous elle est maline hein je vais me
faire l'avocat du attendez voilà je vais
me faire l'avcat du diable mais Xavier
si vous devez vous faire opérer de
l'appendicite à Singapour ça va vous
coûter un bras c'est vrai bah alors
c'est là où les gar rentrent mais c'est
là où je gueule les gars entrent
effectivement pour se faire opérer ce
qui est scandaleux
donc là mais là bien sûr ça c'est pas
bien mais c'est on est sur les
cacahuètes hein on est parce que le vrai
truc à faire le vrai truc à faire c'est
de baisser parce que si vous baissez les
dépenses voyez vous vous on on on on on
on travaille aussi longtemps qu'on
devrait hein donc 67 ans 40 he et si on
met la sphère publique à ce moment-là on
gagne en gros lors de 300 milliards bon
300 milliards sur le PIP de00 ça fait 13
%. la dépense publique passe de 57 à 44
et quand vous êtes à 44 de dépenses
publiqu les pays se prent à croître donc
le vrai truc à faire c'est refaire
croître le pays en donnant un régime
joquet et à ce moment-là tout le système
repart donc ça c'est le vrai message à
passer il faut on est dans l'Europe il
faut qu'on travaille comme nos voisins
européens et le Danemarc je m'excuse
c'est pas un bagne hein bon l'Allemagne
c'est pas un bagne hein il travaillent
plus que nous mais bon quand même oui
moi je suis retraité je travaille autant
quand j'étais chez Silor grâce à vous
bon je suisux très heureux vous payez
vos los en France ah ben bien sûr
évidemment ah ben non mais attendez moi
on m'a proposé quand je suis quand on
m'a proposé de de deux pays m'ont
proposé de devenir de je le citerai pas
deux pays avec des jobs me disant
xaviergal oui c'esténégal je pas pas non
de deux grands pays avec des très gros
Jobs en disant perd très gros Jobs bah
j'étais administrateur d'un des plus
grands fonds du monde combien ça
rapporte ah c'était très élevé je sais
pas j'ai pas voulu rentrer mais c'est
des sommes très élevées mais j'ai dit
donc je suis français il y a combien de
zé à un milliard comment il a combien de
Z 9 90 oui 6 à 1 million oui oui non non
céit pas de ces là non non on quand même
déjà d'administrateur non mais alors moi
j'ai voulu rester français peut-être à
cause de mon père qui était en politique
et en fait moi j'ai choisi une carrière
de business pas de politique mais j'ai
ce petit côté papa travailler avec le
général voilà bien sûr et P Pidou
surtout bon vous avez ça ce petit truc
au fond de vous je le sens dans toutes
vos question c'est très bien donc moi
j'ai aucun problème et je suis très
content je suis beaucoup plus heureux à
discuter avec vous que m'emmerder sur un
bateau quelque part dans les Caraïbes
j'ai strictement je préfère ouais on
s'emmerde alors là on s'amuse donc je
préfère 100 fois et je prendrai le métro
pour rentrer et je serai très heureux et
donc je suis ravi d'avoir fait mon choix
mais il faut aussi qu'on nous écoute un
peu donc merci de poliitique un peu oui
bien sûr oui alors je vous laisse foncer
non alors attendez maintenant sur
l'énergie sur l'énergie alors il se
trouve que moi vous avez compris j'ai
une retraite hyper active et que mon
créneau c'est la pédagogie de l'économie
il se trouve que grâce à mes émissions
BCG BFM on m'a demandé de donner des
cours à l'X au MIN et et maintenant au
knnam Nam et je me suis rendu compte en
discutant avec les élèves de l'X et des
m qui sont évidemment très soucieux de
l'avenir énergétique bon donc je me suis
plongé je me suis plongé dans ce inview
donc j'ai décortiqué toutes les
interviews de jeanovissi bon qui fait un
travail absolument exceptionnel he bon
alors je suis pas d'accord sur tout mais
je suis donc j'ai ça donc j'ai commencé
à me documenter j'ai un autre domaine
comme mon côté breton je donne beaucoup
de cours de stratégie aux éleveurs de
porc donc la coperle qui est la plus
grosse coopérative et donc je suis
rentré dans tout le sujet de la
méthanisation qui est une source
d'énergie considérable donc vous voyez
je suis rentré dans le truc donc j'ai
pas mal d'élément sur l'énergie et alors
j'ai fait un jeu stratégie alors vous
raconterai comment c'est arrivé où j'ai
modélisé spcft voà Sparcraft bien sûr
alors je connais s bien sûr tous ces
jeux-là alors je pense que trèsfempur
bien sûr ETF absolument et ça si vous
voulez je pense qu'en terme pédagogique
c'est extrêmement important parce que ça
développe l'esprit de stratégie et je
pense que ça devrait être dans les cours
ça devrait dans les classes hein on
devrait mettre ça dans lesation
nationale pas en faire trop mais en
faire un peu parce que c'est la pure
stratégie ou jouer contre des gens
intelligents ben c'est ça la stratégie
hein et donc ça c'est ça on est donc ce
sont des cours alors ce que j'ai fait
j'ai modélisé si vous voulez le grand
truc dans la stratégie c'est définir le
champ concurrentiel j'avais expliquer la
course d'expérience la finance le
troisième truc c'est définir le terrain
de bataille comment est-ce qu'on bat
terrain de guerre c'est ça exactement et
comment est-ce que vous définissez quel
est Chang géographique quelles sont les
caractéristiques techniques pour se
battre et quels sont les concurrents
hein donc c'est faire un échiquier alors
j'ai fait un échiquier de toute
l'énergie européenne dans laquelle on a
mis les pétroles
donc les pétroliers sont
fondamentalement dans l'exploration et
la distribution de pétrole est un
gigantesque business ensuite il y a les
électriciens qui sont dans les centrales
à charbon les centrales nucléaires
énergie nouvelle et
distributionélectricité et puis vous
avez tous les mineurs qui sont dans la
production de charbon et dans les mines
pour faire les batteries voilà donc j'ai
et donc je me suis amusé à faire un
échiquier dans lequel on met les
business que je vous écrit et on met
tous les concurrents on met total on met
total shell BP on met
EDF hydrolal espagnol on met le
l'allemand rou l'italien voyez bon puis
après vous mettez Glencore qui est une
des plus grosses sociétés du monde que
personne connaît et puis vous mettez BHP
Hilton bon après vous mettez les actifs
qu's ont dans tous les créneaux et puis
vous détuisez les rentabilités et puis
vous les faites investir alors vous
faites monter les marchés d'électricité
alors moi la grande tèse que j'ai si
vous voulez et là je dis je c'est pour
moi une après avoir beaucoup réfléchi
avec les élèves des mines si vous voulez
c'est la fé électricité qui va nous
régler parce que quand vous commencez à
regarder les chiffres dans le détail que
vous découpez la France dans les
différents créneaux vous avez le
transport le bâtiment l'industrie
l'agriculture que vous regardez
l'énergie dépensée d'accord et que vous
regardez les émissions de CO2 vous
trouvez un graphite extraordinaire c'est
que les émissions de CO2 par énergie
hein par trawatur d'énergie elles sont
elles descendent avec la part de marché
d'électricité quand l'électricité a une
grosse part de marché les émissions de
CO2 sont toutes petites électricité
nucléaire alors oui l'électricité alors
elle elle est nucléaire et l'énergie
nouvelle elle a différentes qualités
charbon comme en allem peut être charbon
aussi non mais attendez attendez
attendez on va y aller par étape donc
vous première constatation c'est que les
émissions de CO2 descend avec avec la
montée alors aujourd'hui vous savez que
l'énergie totale en France c'est 1650
TWh et qu'en gros l'électricité on a vu
que c'est l'ordre de 480 donc
l'électricité c'est l'ordre de 25 25 28
%. si vous montez à horizon 50 la part
de la f électricité à 65 %. vous
effondrez les émissions de CO2 et à ce
moment-là la France elle est neutre
parce qu'il y a une partie quand même
qui se du CO2 qui est digérée
automatiquement par les forêts et par
les et par les océans et donc la grande
stratégie c'est de monter EDF à 65 % par
marché de l'énergie pour faire ça faut
évidemment des voitures électriques mais
le grand D le gros truc qui est
compliqué il faut financer tout toute
l'arsenal donc faut arrêter les
centrales à charbon donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut monter le nucléaire il faut
monter le il faut monter les énergies
nouvelles je peux vous perturber allez-y
là je vais vous rajouter des paramètres
de stress réchauffement climatique et
des paramètres de stress de type pénurie
ou de de difficulté d'accessibil alors
je réponds tout de suite je vous réponds
tout de suite justement la l'habilité de
mon raisonnement qui consiste à dire que
la fée électricité va faire tomber
complètement CO2 c'est qu'à ce moment-là
vous réglez le problème à 2050 et vous
allez voir qu' moi ma conviction absolue
c'est l'énergie nucléaire et les
énergies nouvelles al moi je suis très
énergie très énergie nucléaire hein de
quel type alors attendez alors justement
alors j'ai un débat moi je suis
absolument convaincu qu'on va arriver à
la fusion plus vite que prévu inall
alors non non non j'ai des tat tuyau
alors dans le renseignement vous voulez
du renseignement ça vous amuse ça nous
amuse pas connais je connais des
Français je connais des Français
d'accord ce dont les non non non non
c'est beaucoup plus malin que ça don les
gendres
travaillent dans les
omit dans le rédacteur nucléaire de
fusion donc j'ai les tuyaux qui viennent
directement bon et ben ils sont
persuadés qu'ils vont y arriver j'ai des
tuyaux actuellement au Japon ils sont en
train de réussir des fusions nucléaires
qui durent une minute à 2 minutes bon
vous avez les les Chinois qui sont en
train d'y arriver et et donc il y a y a
et puis alors le plus important c'est
qu'il y a un groupe allemand qui vient
de se mettre à la fusion nucléaire qui
vient de trouver un truc comement génial
donc moi je suis persuadé que la fusion
va arriver plus vite que prévu alors ce
sont des intuitions et c'est les des
signaux faibles précurseurs ouais mais
quand un grand opticien me dit mon
gendre qui est un type complèement
génial qui a Félix il travaille bon
voyez d'accord et là j'ai un type que je
connais bien qui est un mec génial on a
des tuyaux là-dessus et puis j'ai j'ai
vu aussi des j'ai des tuyaux qui
viennent un peu de partout aussi hein et
et et donc alors même sans fusion
nucléaire je pense qu'avec des petits
réacteurs nucléaires qui vont être fait
en grande série avec des coures
d'expérience dessus donc moi je crois
beaucoup que le nucléaire est la
solution il faut que la France devienne
retrouve sa position de numéro 1 mondial
de nucléaire parce qu'à ce momentlà vous
réglez tout hein je peux je peux vous
vous mettre un
autre la prospec allezy stressez-moi moi
j'aime bien on fait une expérience de
pensée admettons on a une énergie pas
chère à volonté pour les 500 prochaines
années qu'est-ce qui se passe avec oh
bah ça c'est qu'est-ce qui se passe
quand on a mis dans la tête des jeunes
de la société d'hyperconsommation de la
société est-ce queon va se retrouver
avec des pénuries sur autre chose ah ben
qui vont exacerber les tensions par
exemple le cuivre par exemple des terres
rares par exemple tout ça est-ce que
sans
basculement de la psychologie sociétale
du vivre ensemble de comment consommer
ah oui oui d'accord ah ben faut bien sûr
travailler sur consommer moins mais je
pense la nouvelle génération moi je vois
avec mes enfants mes petitsenfants tout
ce que je vois autour de moi c'est
vachement sérieux oui par exemple on
fait plus de VO de vacances ils veulent
plus qu'on aille passer des vacances
Mons au Caraïbes à cause des avions ah
ben ils sont tous moi dans ma famille on
va on reste on utilise le train et moi
la nouvelle génération ils sont
vachement moi je trouve qu'ils sont très
très dur sur le sur la consommation
réduire les consommations moi je crains
moins ça voyez et puis l'idée que
l'énergie infinie non l'autre truc qui
va arriver je pense c'est qu'il y a des
gens qui perent la côte terrestre pour
joindre magma la géothermie ouais ah non
non beaucoup plus que ça la géothermie
c'est ridicule c'est 100°gr non non on
descend on touche le magma ça c'est la
quantité d'énergie infinie hein il y a
trois quatre projets hein pas connu des
Français non non non non non non
américains Israël et tout ça ils persent
profondément hein et donc mais je pense
que le nucléaire va faire les choses et
alors si vous voulez le truc le plus
important c'est que le jeu montre hein
alors vous irez voir c'est le jeu numéro
300 BFM stratégie allez voir l'émission
le plus important c'est que quand vous
faites un calcul de capital et moi c'est
ce que j'apporte par rapport notamment à
jankovish c'est que moi je calcule tous
les capitaux et les vachalis que sont le
pétrole et la et le charbon parce que ce
qui se passe c'est que le pétrole va
tomber mais quand le pétrole tombe ça
génère un cash phénoménal c'est que en
fait les les pétroliers ils ont pu
investir donc tout le bénéfice il se
transforme en cash et quand vous faites
les calculs de tous les capitaux engagés
et bien le cash des pétroliers des
mineurs est largement suffisant pour
financer la filière énergétique
nucléaire donc il suffit de pas emmerder
DF comme on le fait actuellement en
disant laissez les prix et on vous pique
pas vos bénéfices comme on le fait à ce
moment-là et alors c'est très amusant
c'est que vous avez largement le fric
pour faire une très très belle boîte
d'EDF alors le truc le plus marrant
c'est que mes petits jeunes qui ont
gagné le jeu stratégi vous verrez 300
bon après l'miss ils étaient tout s but
pe passer à la télé donc je les invite à
déjeuner on discute entre eux et le
gagnant le gagnant me dit monieur Fanet
alors moi je crois EDF et quand on met
avec mon jeu on voit un EDF si vous
voulez si vous laissez EDF devenir
leader européen alors là vraiment on les
laisse écraser tout le monde hein les
Allemands vont pas être contents ils
vont pas être contents mais on investit
alors attendez ça va changer l'allemand
parce que le nouveau qui est élu le
nouveau qui est élu il est il est pas
contre très très important hein alors
les Italiens sont pour les Espagnols
sont pour on laisse DF vraiment devenir
un vrai leader européen comme les sil
dans les vers vous arrivez à des moi
j'arrive à des capis de 1000 à 2000
milliards de capis et c'est tout à fait
normal parce que l'énergie c'est le plus
gros business de tout beaucoup plus gros
la bagnoleénergie et donc à ce moment-là
les petits jeunes ont dit mais monsieur
Fontanet il faut remettref en bourse
nous on met des actions et notre
retraite sera payée par EDF vous rendez
compte les jeunes à pleurer alors
celui-là je vais le faire venir à la
télé j'irai même pas l'émission il
racontera ça parce qu'il va être plus
crédible que moi donc si vous voulez je
suis peut-être trop optimiste mais j'ai
vraiment creusé le truc et je me suis
payé tous les bilans de tous les
électriciens j'ai fait vérifier les
chiffres d's EDF m'a dit Xavier c'est
formidable votre truc et ils m'ont aidé
à vérifier les chiffres hein bon et donc
je pense qu'il y a une vraie solution
c'est l'Europe leader mondial dans le
nucléaire parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est les
Coréens les Russes qui nous emmerdent
mais je pense que si on s'y met nous on
va être beaucoup plus fort parce que
c'est exact les trucs où où les Français
sont très bons et puis et puis si donc
si on remet le le nucléaire et on laisse
EDF sans l'emmerder sur les prix et vous
savez que ce qui se passe c'est que les
pétroliers à mon avis il vont rentrer
aussi dans l'électricité ils vont
dominer l'énergie nouvelle donc total va
dem l'énergie nouvelle à mon avis les
mineurs peuvent rentrer en électricité
total peut rentrer dans l'électricité à
ce moment-là ça allège le capital d'df
qui n'a plus que du fric à fooutre dans
le nucléaire il est très possible qu'un
jour euh un pétrolier rentre dans le
nucléaire hein lisez le rapport d'Aramco
vous allez voir c'est passionnant Aramco
savez risque d'acheter des des boîtes de
Bagnol ils rentrent dans les batteries
hein donc c'est les pétroliers sont très
malins hein et euh et alors moi je pense
par contre il faut expliquer ça il faut
l'expliquer aux politiques et je
m'excuse mais à momenté il faut
s'asseoir euh et leur dire attendez là
vous êtes en train de casser les prix
d'EDF pour que il mettent pas des prix
trop élevés vouz piquer ses des
dividendes ridicules euh laissez-les
investir laisser les faire et surtout
vous les laisser se développer dans
toute l'Europe et là vous créez une
boîte magnifique et je dis les Français
on met notre capital dedans parce que
moi je je F tout de suite mon fric dans
cette boî là si on me garantit qu'on
leur lâche les baskets moi je connais
bien Luc grmont parce que j'étais
administrateur de Schneider on dit au
père Raymond écoute tu as un truc tu as
15 ans devant toi et on te demande
d'être leader là-dedans et puis après
ils rachèteront ils berdront là tout ça
ça s'arrangera ou ils auront des boîtes
ils veront une boîte Franco espagolle ou
franco-italienne européenne et là on
peut devenir leader mondial et ça après
cette boîteel peut partir dans le monde
entier donc c'est de l'Europe elle est
fantastique quel regard vous portez sur
nos stratèges qui se trouvent en haut de
l'État nos politiciens attendez alors le
problème un are monde non c'est des
alors c'est le monde politique faut pas
le jeter la pierre parce que c'est un
monde qui est compliqué mais il vivent
vraiment entre eux si vous voulez y a
moi ce que je rêverais je vous dis tout
de suite et votre émission Vaé c'est de
faire un cours de stratégie à tous les
députés
on prend les députés les sénateurs et le
gouvernement il se trouve qu'il y a une
fille qui était donc qui a fait ça
c'était valéie PCR elle avait compris
alors je vous jure que c'est vrai elle
elle arrivé des plateaux repas à
l'Assemblée et le père Fontanet donnait
des cours de stratégie au députés
pendant les repas et ben ça a vachement
joué puis ça s'est arrêté parce qu'elle
est parti je sais plus quoi mais il faut
il faut rapprendre il faudrait que les
députés passent un exam exam d'économie
pour qu'ils viiennent députés enfin ils
sont élus mais on leur demande de passer
un examen d'économie s'ils comprennent
rien ils peuvent pas se présenter parce
qu' moment donné c'est dramatique à un
moment donné ou alors s'ils ont pas on
les forme mais vous rendez compte les je
discutis avec des députés alors ils
disent les résultats de total c'est
obsène bon 20 milliards je dis monsieur
le député quel est le chif d'affaires de
Total ah je connais pas ben je vous le
donne 200 milliards quels sont députés
les capitaux propres de Total
c'est quoi les capitaux propres non
monsieur le député quels sont les
capitaux propres de total 140 milliards
bon alors 20 milliards avant impôts ça
fait 14 milliards après impôt 14
milliards sur 120 ça fait 12 % je
m'excuse c'est très élevé mais il va
payer un dividende de 30 % il reste que
9 on 9 sur 200 ben ça fait une
croissance de 4 et demi je vais vous
dire voyez mais ils sont pas capables de
faire ce raisonnement et alors le
problème c'est qu'ils comprennent pas
que il faut vous calculez les marges non
pas par rapport au chif d'affaires par
au capitaux EDF vous savez les capitaux
l'ensemble des actifs d'EDF c'est 350
milliards pour un chiffre d'affairire de
120 donc ça veut dire qu'il faut 3 € de
capital pour 1 € de chiffre d'affaires
alors vous rendez compte donc si on
commence à dire il fut une marge de 20 %
bah oui sur chi d'affaires mais 20 %
c'est 7 % sur capital 7 % c'est c'est
pas mal mais c'est pas assez si on veut
les faire croître voilà alors le
résultat est obsè mais il est pas il
calcule ça sur chif d'affair et pas sur
capitaux donc vous rendez compte le
travail à faire compte si je vous dis 10
€ de dette pour 1 € de croissance ça
c'est quoi c'est de la cavalerie ça
c'est la France oui non mais mais je
vous aurais embouché cher amis hein oh
là là je vous aurais rencontré je vous
aurais tout de suite proposé de rentrer
chez Silor mais vous êtes probablement
beaucoup mieux là mais effectivement
alors le problème très grave de la
France c'est qu'on a pas de croissance
puisqu'on était on n pas de croissance
et la dette monte c'est que la
rentabilité est dégueulasse vous
comprenez c'est pour ça qu'il faut faire
maigrir le jquet il faut ramener la
dépense publique à 44 % du PIB ce qui
permet en gros à toute l'Europe de
croître mais effectivement le problème
que vous mentionnez c'est parce que le
joket est trop lourd donc il y a un lien
tout fait lien si vous voulez le il y a
un lien entre la vitesse de
l'endettement et la part de la sphère
publique dans le PIB mais qui explique
ça il y a pas un seul alors je vous
demandez à tous mes collègues du du 440
les dire tout ça on va tous vous dire ça
parce que nous c'est notre vie mais les
économistes font pas ça et c'est ce
qu'il faut expliquer aux députés alors
nous si voulez on est on a on a anticipé
ça depuis 30 ans hein c'est 30 ans qu'on
a vu le truc hein donc voilà mais le
truc à faire c'est des cours de CD mais
vous savez je vais vous dire votre
émission elle va faire un tabac on va
s'amuser à la circuler on va l'envoyer
pour que tous les députés l'écoutent et
puis si vous voulez on en fait une autre
moi je vous fais un petit cours de
stratégie et puis on la balance au
députés au sénateurs là je m' je m'en
occupe he et puis je demande à mes
copains de qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec le
modèle de décroissance notre société
rentre dans un modèle de décroissance ah
non il faut accep faut le refuser alors
comment on fait bah attendez le monde
est en croissance il faut prendre des
part marchés il faut maigrir il faut
donner un régime jocket c'est pas la
alors qu'ils vont tous dire rigueur non
c'est un régime jockeet le jockeet les
Haut- fonctionnaires sont remarquabl moi
je connais des tas il sont exceptionnels
c'est le système qui est mal foutu hein
c'est trop central
les régions tout ça ça il y a les tas de
trucs je suis sûr qu'on mettrait des
chefs d'entreprise avec des hauts
fonctionnaires avec une vraie mission
c'est un peu ce que fait musk hein bon
mais une vraie mission plus plus
raisonnable on ferait ça ensemble en
mettant les talents d'ensemble moi je
vous persuider qu'on REM les trucs sur
pied hein attendez les exemples ils sont
il y a 1300 agences attendez bon les
rond-points qu'est-ce qu'on fait on va
arrêter les rond-points on continue à
faire les rond-points il y en a trop on
a il un truc qu'il faut arrêter c'est
tellement évident ça sert à autre chose
la rond-point peut-être financer
quelques campagnes oui mais attendez
alors après oui vous comprenez le
problème du rond-point c'est que ça
monte les impôts il faut arrêter les
rond-points baisser les impôts et ça met
de l'argent dans le mec qui va mettre
des machines outils pour embaucher du
monde regarde vous regardez que vous
portez sur Trump et sur Elion musque je
veux pas sortir de mon humble situation
si vous voulez moi j'ai si bon faut
respecter les un président les
États-Unis donc bon puis faut respecter
faut respecter bon alors c'est pas tout
à fait B j'aurais pas su pas sûr
j'aurais vé pour lui là si vous voulez
moi le truc qui me fait mal parce que
j'adore l'Amérique bon je dois beaucoup
à l'Amérique à cause du MTI parce que si
vous vouz siarrêz au BCG c'est grâce au
MTI donc moi j'ai passé des ans avec mon
épous extrêmement heureux à MH et
Harvard et moi j'ai toujours été bluffé
par le côté si les Américains faut voir
que les
Américains les grands américains tout ce
qui concerne la démocratie les concerné
rosevelt il a quand même décidé d'aider
l'Europe contre l'Allemagne vous voyez
bon il y a donc une culture américaine
c'est quand même des Européens les
Français les ont aidés contre la
perfidealbillon avec la faillette il y a
quand même des liens énormes il y a une
tradition séculaire de de solidarité et
là le président Trump il coupe il coupe
une tradition de alors moi c'est que ça
alors je pense qu'on verra vous allez
voir dans quelques temps les Américains
il va y avoir des gens qui vont
commencer à dire ça va pas hein mais bon
c'est comme ça c'est le président bah
ils l'ont élu on fait avec mais j'espère
qu'il se fait pas rouler par Poutine
parce que le père Poutine il est très
malin qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec musque
musque on fait quoi bah mus c'est le
choix du président putin c'est un joueur
d'échec ou c'est un joueur de go ah
c'est un non mais Poutine il est super
malin là il a alors Trump je sais pas ce
qu'il a joué mais Trump a tout filé il a
tout filé à Poutine un seul coup et en
sentendant voyez il aurait pu alors
est-ce que Trump dit écoute Poutine si
tu commences à dire on va continuer la
on va continuer la on va continuer la
guerre parce que moi je pense que en
terme de stratégie je pense que la
Russie mon petit instinct c'est que la
Russie est en mauvais état hein et que
donc pourquoi pourquoi bah
économiquement hein économie de guerre
qui va réclamer de plus pour vous avez
vu les taux d'intérêt vous avez taux
d'intérêtit 15 % ah ouais et puis vous
avez vu ils sont tenus par la Chine
parce que la Chine leur a passé
d'énormes commandes de gaz supposez que
la Chine paye pas en dis oh le gaz il y
a des un peu d'air vous vous rendez
compte donc la Chine les aide encore la
Chine était pas très content de ce qui
s'est passé avec les Coréens je sais pas
si vous suivi donc bon d' autre côté je
pense que Trump il veut peut-être joue
je suis pas sûr de tout comprendre mais
je trouve qu'il a il a tout de suite
tout donné à Poutine si vous voulez
alors par contre Poutine le danger qui
lui court c'est que si la guerre dure et
qu'on aide les Ukrainiens avec des bons
armements et tout ça l'économie virus
est en mauvais état alors est-ce que
est-ce est-ce que non non est-ce que
est-ce que Trump va dire bon jeis la
stratégie je vous dis en entreprise
vraiment je crois que je m'y connais
là-dessus je m'y connais pas plus que
vous mais si Poutine dit écout Trump si
si Trump dit Poutine fait pas chier
parce que sinon sinon je va dire on va
aider les ukrainiens et la guerre elle
va durer et je vais dire les comptes les
comptes tu vas voir hein c'est est-ce
qu'il joue ça est-ce qu'il joue ça de
temps musk musque musk c'est un génie
musk alors si musk c'est un honnêtement
faut être faut être honnête c'est un
quand on voit ce qu'il a fait avec les
Paypal avec c'est un véritable génie
maintenant est-ce qu'il a pas la tête un
peu trop grosse et
cetera est-ce que c'est stable c'est
quand même des gars un peu excités hein
donc combien de temps ça va durer
combien de temps ça va durer moi je
pense qu'il faut là actuellement la
situation est extrêmement dur moi je
pense que si j'étais dirigeant français
je dirais au français c'est extrêmement
grave beaucoup plus grave vous croyez au
petit truc maintenant on va monter d'un
cran un peu comme Napoléon
dirait pourquoi c'est grave
ahendearrer on risque de se faire
déclasser pour les 30 prochaines
années si onarrête pas
Poutine attendez alors après il va être
pris par l'âge mais il est encore en
bonne santé donc fait comment pour
occuper des territoires sur la
démographie qui va avec comment on fait
comment pour occuper un territoire quand
on n pas la démographie qui su oui bah
c'est ça non mais ils ont des visions si
vous voulez je pense qu'ils ont des
visions de territoire ils visent des
matières premières ils visent le blé il
vise ça voyez donc il a un business
model dans lequel il prend des
territoires pour pouvoir augmenter son
PIB donc ce qui perd sur l'industrie
parce que son l'industrie écement Chao
si vous voulez il il le rattrape en
prenant des territoires en prenant des
mines il veut des mines il veut du blé
et il veut des voyez du pétrole et du
gaz donc ça il non il est très logique
hein bon simplement le truc qu' a c'est
queut oui il faut pas négliger faut un
concurrent faut jamais négliger hein
quand il est arrivé quand les gens sont
arrivés là bon c'est pas forcément des
gens quient comme nous mais ils sont
Bonsin faire attention faut bien les
comprendre non pas du tout pas du tout
pas du tout non moi je connais les moi
je connais mes concurrents j'ai connais
tous les concurrents des Silor de REST
et de Beneto ça je les connaissais comme
ma poche mais je suis honnêtement la
géopolitique n'est pas un domaine dans
lequel dans lequel je me suis mais je
pense que il faut vraiment que les
Européens se rendent compte que la
situation est grave et il faut il faut
faire des il faut faire des sacrifices
hein pour ça si vous aviez des conseil
de chef d'entreprise de capitaine
d'industrie à donné à nos services de
renseignement ce serait quoi bah lire
mes
livres évidemment non euh je pense que
non non je ben ce qui se passe si vous
voulez c'est que le livre en fait un
gros succès je m'excuse mais vous allez
voir ça va vous intéresser et vous savez
comment ça marche c'est
une petite intro à la pierre pierre
Belmar on y va alors comment ça marche
non non mais c'est qu'en fait les gens
achètent des caisses ils achètent des
caisses de livrees et il les distribué à
leur cadre et il me demande de venir
commenter le bouquin une fois que les
gens voyz alors je veux dire j'ai deux à
trois demandes par
jour je fais ça tout à fait alors
amicalement tout à fait gratos je veux
pas du tout je fais comme vous on est on
commence à se comprendre parce que il y
a une petite cé de partage voyez et donc
oui al sens créatif comm al c'est
extraordinaire j'avais la semaine
dernière j'ai une équipe alors boî je
peux pas donner son nom mais c'était
prodigieux des génies ce sont en gros de
GGN des hackurs donc votre boîte est
hackée et vous avez des jeunes
complètement géniaux donc c'est des
jeunes 303 32 ans quiest qui débarque il
débarque il vous répare le truc il vous
mett en place un système qui protège al
cette boîte là les gens travaillent chez
eux il y a pas de siège la seule réunion
qu'ils ont c'est une réunion dans une
capitale par que la boîte est l'éc
européenne il se trouvait que c'était à
Paris donc le gars avait acheté 50
bouquins il avait doné ça tous les
cadres et j'ai passer un long petit
déjeuner une petite matinée avec tout le
monde à répondre aux questions ils
étaent
enthousiaste voyz et il ont même fait
des petits cadeaux qui est parti à
l'Ukraine voilà voyez par que dès que VO
j'ai un truc je j'envoie du fric à
l'Ukraine à le MSF voilà ils sont très
gentils MSF au moins ça et donc vous
voyez alors alors ça j'adore parce que
ils étaent heureux et donc je pens
j'avais j'avais la semaine dernière
alors un truc incroyable un Private
Equity donc il avait g 3 milliards il
avait h boîtes c'est un petit il avait
donné il avait acheté 50 bouquins et les
C les CIN patrons des des des h boîtes
ils sont venus et ils m'ont interviewé
alors en plus j'étais j'étais filmé vous
mez sur sur linkeding ils ont pris les
bons moments
extraordinairees il é tous enthousiastes
le père fontaner était ravi alors
qu'est-ce qu'il y a comme conseil pour
les services de renseignement pour
protéger notre industrie nos services de
renseignement économique il faut surtout
dire ben il faudrait qu'il se renseigne
sur les prix de reviens des différents
états et qui demande à la France
d'arriver au prix de revient qu'on les a
donc il faut qu'il aille voir aux
Pays-Bas il faut qu'il aille voir en
Allemagne dis écoutez là je crois que
c'est là qui est le truc le vrai
concurrent en fait c'est l'état c'est
que il faut que l'État comprenne que lui
est en concurrence avec les autres États
et que c'est pas à lui de donner des
conseils au cheval c'est à lui de
voyez le cheval il est excellent les
chevaux sont géniaux prenez une boîte
comme Schneider c'est une boîte
complètement géniale ils sont ils sont
rattrapés quasiment zemens zens et Scher
ont cogné de général électriquez c'est
des boîtes extraordinaires Air Liquide
ils sont en train de devenir leader
mondial avec l'allemand l' 2 ils ont
racheté les Américains les regardez
regardez Airbus airbus est en train de
coller une claque à Boeing c'est
vachement intéressant elle est énorme la
claque qui porte regardez les pourquoi
la claque d'ailleurs bah c'est sur
problème opérationnel je pense que
laaméie il y a eu un vrai sujet c'est
que la Californie est exceptionnelle
mais je pense que les industries de base
regardez les bagnoles General Motors
tout ça alors il y a il y a le phénomène
il y a le phénomène musque c'est ca mais
les autres regardez tout ça c'est tombé
alors les avions regardez toute
l'électricité regardez les téléphone
Cisco qui était la plus grosse boîte du
monde il y a 30 ans il sont fait cogner
par il donc je crois que les américains
ils ont un vrai sujet industriel et
c'est pas les droits de douanes qui vont
arranger ça hein par que saz quand vous
protégez une industrie par les droits de
douanes on donne du temps on monte les
prix c'est pas ça qui arrange he et donc
et donc on n pas on n pas au bout du
truc donc ça va très intéressant à
suivre ça très intéressant suivre
comment vous voyez la la la France et la
stratégie française au milieu de tous
ces gros requin est-ce qu'on est
dimensionné pour aller à la chasse
est-ce qu'on est dimension ouis al moi
je suis un grand Européen moi je crois
en Europe si vous voulez si je crois à
l'Europe je vais vous dire j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi à l'Europe et je me suis senti
européen
quand j'ai travaillé en Chine en Inde au
Japon si vous voulez on devient européen
alors d'où ça vient pour moi l'Europe ça
a commencé avec avec on fait de la philo
mais ça va vous intéresser on commence
avec Socrate on commence avec pour moi
Socrate c'est le premier qui s a posé le
doute et le doute pour moi c'est l'être
humain l'identité c'est le doute à
l'avant il y avait mythologie grec on
pose une question alors ça c'est le
doute après vous avez toute la période
avec saint-omas d'quin donc les curés
commencer à comprendre que la religion
c'était du l'ordre personnel et pas du
l'ordre de l'État donc il y a eu la cité
qui est arrivé il y a eu après Kant
évidemment Kant et Voltaire
monstrueusement important parce que là
toute l'âme européenne elle est là voyez
alors après il y a eu heidger derida
tout ça je TR ça nul et donc habitable
doncement nul pour moi mais on on a et
je me suis rendu compte si vous voulez
de de ce qu'est l'Europe avec ça et pour
moi le génie de l'Europe on l'a trouvé
avec quand Einstein et Bor on ont
découvert la relativité et alors moi je
suis incapable de jeér des ponts mais je
comprends en gros de quoi il s'agit mais
je peux pas rentrer dans les détail mais
il s'est passé un phénomène génial vous
aviez des Italiens des Allemands des
Autrichiens des Danois des Anglais des
Français et et puis un suisse qui était
Einstein tout ce petit monde ensemble
était allemand avant non il était
allemand et allemand il est parti en
Suisse puis après il est parti aux
États-Unis bon et euh et donc vous avez
là vous avez le génie absolu qui s et
moi j'ai vu dans voyez bon on est marié
avec un italien mais vous avez le génie
italien qui se mari avec le génie
français les G italiens sont géniaux les
Italiens pas les mêmes trucs que nous
hein et puis les Français on a on a du
vrai génie j'ai beaucoup de avec
les Allemands bon on a un génie par
rapport aux Allemands les Allemands est
génie par rapport à nous Airbus c'est
quoi c'est que moi forgard et je connais
bien forgard Airbus c'est un un Français
patron de l'industrie qui s'est entendu
avec son avec son allemand vous avez le
génie français et et la rigueur
allemande qui ont travaillé pas en 40
c'est ça qui a fait Airbus donc l'Europe
est génial moi je suis convaincu j'ai
j'ai lutté contre des Japonais contre
des Coréens contre tout le monde je vous
dis l'Europe est un génie et donc il
faut simplement remettre ça et et on
aura une place dans le monde alors on
est très différent des Chinois on est
différent des Américains on est très
différent des Indiens très différent des
Japonais mais on a un génie moi j'y
crois beaucoup et il y a un très bon
bouquin qui s'appelle les autres ne
pensent pas comme nous ah oui sûr ben je
connais l'ambassadeur il était
ambassadeur au Japon bien sûr c'est
unancien ambassadeur attendez mais oui
mais attendez quand je vous disais les
ambassadeurs sont géniaux moi Gour
monontagne ben lui je le connais très
bien parce que il était ambassadeur au
Japon et alors si vous voulez et sior a
été au Japon un des plus beauos succès
parce que la boîte ni conorche donc Gour
de montagne m'invitait tout le temps
quand il voulait faire la promotion du
Japon donc je dis même avec G à l'époque
tiens on on dit avec des boîtes
françaises qui voulent investir en au
Japon et on racontait notre expérience
et c'est gourdau monontagne qui montait
ça mais lui on rendit compte la culture
qu'il a avec tout les pays où il a été
en plus il a été dans des grandes jobes
au ministère et en plus du terrain B
vous voyez c'est comme les PDG et nous
je trouve que les grands ambassadeurs on
se sent très proche d'eux parce que
c'est les grands oui non des mecs ils
ont fait à la fois voyez ils ont puis
ils ont des cultures ils sont absolument
extraordinaires moi je les adore hein là
j'ai déjeuné pas longtemps encore avec
un un gars qui avait été ambassadeur aux
États-Unis régal absolu tout ce qu'on
discute et donc je pense que j'espère
qu'on leur donne l'importance qu'ils ont
et il faut aller chercher les retraités
invitez les retraités planchés ici hein
c'est VO vous avez beaucoup vous avez
beaucoup de monde invité finalement on
va vous faire votre liste on invite
bientôt un futur retraité un futur jeune
retraité qui travaille dans l'énergie
mais il faut qu'il s'entraîne encore un
petit peu avant ou il va se sentir il va
comprendre la dédicace d'accord ah
d'accord revenons revenons à votre jeu
quel est le profil des gagnants est-ce
que c'est un profil tout à fait dans les
clous est-ce qu'il y a des profils
atypiques ah oui oui oh là là alors on
va rituer le jeu si vous voulez
euh un jour j'ai un sur Twitter il y a
un gars qui commence à me suivre et donc
bon alors finalement je regarde quiil
est je dis ok finalement on on a les
mail secret puis me dit sur je vais vous
voir bon donc je le reçois et c'est un
gars qui avait une boîte de Serious Game
s'appelle Alexis La Capelle et sa boîte
interactive 4D donc est intéressant sa
première boîte si vous voulez il prend
des infirmières et il apprend une
infirmière qui a aucune qui n'a aucune
formation qui est généraliste on
l'apprend à s'occuper d'une greffe de
rein opération du cœur voyez le truc
comme ça donc c'est un serérius Game qui
apprend les gens il me dit monsieur
fondanet je rêverais de faire un jeu de
stratégie avec vous alors du coup moi
j'ai tout oh ça m'amuse beaucoup et à ce
point-là moi j'ai tout j'ai tout la tête
et donc j'ai conçu un jeu de stratégie
appuyé sur les concepts BCG avec
l'accord du BCG bon et donc le jeu vous
met en situation concurrentielle donc je
simule les échiquiers comme je vous l'ai
expliqué puis après on met toutes les
décisions de d'investissement de
dividends d'émission d'action vous voyez
et le jeu c'est que vous décidez
d'investir ou désinvestir dans les
créneaux hein si vous êtes EDF ben vous
vous vous décidez de pousser le
nucléaire d'arrêter les énergies
nouvelles pousser l'électric vous voyez
bon et puis après vous avez tous vos
résultats tous vos bilans donc on voit
si le bilan tient si vous investissez
trop bah le bilan explose faillite
voyezon donc tout ça le truc est très
sophistiqué et donc c'est le jeu qu'on a
mis sur BFM les profils des gagnants
alors les gagnants alors le coup de
théâtre
absolu le coup de théâtre absolu c'est
que le premier jeu on ait fait sur
l'automobile on voit trois gagnants
arrivés alors alors c'est l'émission je
sais plus combien 171 alors le premier é
un type complèement génial c'était
autodidacte travaillait chez auchamp et
auchamp avait il était rentré en
remplissant les supermarchés hein il a
juste le bac et le gars a gagné alors
comme toujours je lui fais faire la
stratégie si vous regardz l'émission et
le type sublime et ben alors je lui dis
comment vous faites c'était un champion
de jeu à 14 ans il il avait joué comme
vous hein il était gagnant de jeu et
donc il avait décrit alors ce qui est
impressionnant c'est que ce gars alors
la famille au champ les mulers ont vu
que le gars est génial hein parce qu'ils
l'ont vachement formé et bon le 2e alors
le 2è papa ganéen maman elle était elle
était ménagère d'un hôpital voyez le
gars est un génie le gars il est à PACA
il il était patron de la de toute la
gestion privée de la poste pour toute la
région paka 32 ans vous le verrez un
génie et la maman le papa je sais pas ce
qu'il faisait et la maman était des
femmes de ménage dans un hôpital vous
rendez compte donc le mec était génial
et le troisième c'était un fils de
famille c'était les concessionnaires man
sur je sais plus toute une région les
camions voyez les trois hein ils av
aucun effet d'étude poussé et et donc
c'est très intéressant c'est que la
stratégie tout le monde voit la prendre
d'ailleurs je me suis amusé à donner con
stratégie en cours Montessori à des
gosses de 10 ans hein et donc vous
mettez les jeux stratégies entre les
mains de goss de 10 ans vous me laissez
1h et3 leur expliquer les vach même pas
en 1 heure je leur explique les vachalet
du BCG les gosses vous les mettez sur le
jeu ils arrivent très bien à jouer donc
la stratégie c'est ça et vous savez
qu'il y a des agrégés qui ont qui sont
pris des claques et le plus drôle je
assure que l'histoire est vrai le 4e est
un polytechnicien qui me dit Monsieur
Fontanet je suis catastrophé ah bon
pourquoi ben je suis pas passé à la télé
ah bon mais écoutez bon ah ben et ben
vous savez je vous demander une lettre
de recommandation il voulait rentrer
chez Renault il était chez valet
et je lu ai fait une lettre de
recommandation comme quoi il était 4e au
jeu il a été reçu le mec ait faitx il
m'a dit vous savez votre letettre de
recommandation ça compté plus fort que
le que le diplôme de l'X parce que il
avait fait un bon jeu et j'avais dit que
dans le jeu bah il avait un score génial
donc ceux qui critiquent les jeux vidéos
alle je conils sont tort alors par
contre si vous voulez le vrai truc c'est
les jeux de guerre moi je j'ai commencé
si vous voulez à regarder de près c'est
quand même
épouvantable les les les jeux voustir
dans tous les sens je pense oui et je
pense qu'il y a des tas de trucs des
gosses qui et on a vu des trucs
dramatiques avec des les jeux de
stratégie c'est très bien oui alors moi
je dis à tous les fabricants de jeux il
faut maintenant que vous passiez mon
stratena et que vous fassiez un vous
fassiez un jeu un jeu avec mes jeux
stratégie c'est beaucoup plus riche que
les jeux de guerre est-ce que vous avez
trois livres à conseiller à notre
communauté ah oui oui vous posez la
question alors là vous avez raison parce
que je pense que c'est
le alors le premier c'est sûrement le
livre de PER sur la confiance hein il
s'appelle du miracle en économie c'est
le dernier livre qu'il a écrit il se
trouve que moi j'ai rencontré perfite
par une histoire complètement folle que
je vous raconte parce que c'est encore
le hasard c'est queun jour j'étais donc
j'étais en première parce que à la suite
d'un service que j'avais rendu à spinel
le patron d' DF il le patron de de der
France il mettait tout le temps
surclassé donc j'étais coopérative
ouvrière et Silor on était tout le temps
et bon et je vois une dame sur une
chaise roulante très fatiguée qui à côté
de moi et je demande à la l'OT j'ai
écouté je donne ma place au mari al mon
Fanet et je donne ma place quand je sors
de l'avion il y ait tout le monde et le
mari c'était perfite à la
perfite alors oui hasard de la vie c'est
rondipité bah voilà bon qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé on a on on a pas mal
sympathisé et il écrivait justement du
miracle en économie parce que pfit vous
voyez n'avait pas une bonne connaissance
de l'entreprise il commençait à
s'intéresser à l'économie et on a passé
3 4 après-midi comme celle-là à discuter
donc c'est le plus beau livre sur la
confiance Mo je pense que c'est le plus
beau livre à lire le deuxème livre que
je conseille à lire je pense que c'est
le Jobs isacson
oui is alors Jobs il y a 10 bouquins le
seul bon c'est Isaacson hein il vaut
4,90 € ça vraiment vous allez voir ce
que c'est qu'un génie ce que c'est que
le business il est absolument
passionnant et il y a une dimension
émotionnelle énorme énorme hein donc la
deuxème et et puis le troisième moi je
conseillerai de lire de lire alors la
trilogie de brodel alors brodel est un
est un type très important vousz pas
c'est un grand historien il s'est
intéressé à l'économie du temps long et
Pompidou avait demandé à brodel de
fusionner les cours d'économie
d'histoire et de géographie dans ce
qu'on appelle une gramère des
civilisations et c'était donc Pompidou
avec l'intuition pour les jeunes
Français de il savait très bien que les
cours d'économie ça commencé à débloquer
et c'était vraiment vous avez vous vous
suivez histoire géographie culture et
dans l'histoire vous avez l'histoire
économique des grandes civilisations
chinoises indiennes voyez toutes de
façon à ce que les jeunes Français soit
ça alors c'est ça gram la civilisation
le livre à lire c'est le livre qui est
au-dessus et donc c'est une trilogie
c'est 3 x 800 pages mais c'est
absolument passionnant c'est toute
l'histoire du capitalisme et vous
commencez
en gros à Venise et et donc vous al vous
avez 1000 ans de perspective historique
et vous avez la mondialisation nacente à
couper le souffle et moi je pense
qu'avec ces trois bouquins ça va vous
donner pas mal de temps voilà les trois
bouquins que je recommander est-ce que
vous croyez en Dieu oui bien sûr bien
sûr mais bon mais je pense queprès c'est
une histoire de si c'est pour moi c'est
un don c'est que tout je comprends très
bien que des gens ne soient pas pas mais
moi j'ai toujours je crois la trans ça
alors moi le truc que je dis quand je ça
ben regardez un
enfant regardez un petit enfant passer 1
heure avec un gosse un gosse d'un an
puis après allez dans un champ regardez
une petite fleur hein puis après
intéressez-vous à un petit oiseau puis
vous suivez l'oiseau pendant hein il y a
quelque chose alors ça m'a beaucoup aidé
si vous voulez parce que je crois à la
transcendance est-ce que vous avez un
conseil pour les jeunes générations une
bouteille à la mer quelque chose
d'impérissable
ben moi je crois que c'est la lecture
moi je CIS faut faire attention à la
vidéo et moi je pose tous mes petits
enfants à
lire à lire énormément alors moi ça
dépend les âges voyez mais je pense
qu'il faut absolument lire les livres de
Jules Verne faut lire l'Î au trésor il
faut lire les trois mousquetaires voyez
il faut lire des il faut lire pour moi
les misérables il faut lire aussi
pagnolut bien sûr il faut lire Pagnol et
je pense qu'il y a une bibliothèque
idéale pour les jeunes Français mais
Pagnol évidemment c'est à pleurer de
beauté et puis oui bien sûr et puis moi
bon Les Misérables jeou ça magnifique
l'Î au trésor tous ces bouquins je
trouve les trois mousquetre c'est quand
même pas mal à lire voyez donc voilà un
petit peu alors moi je dis les enfants
faut les faire lire il faut leur
redonner la lecture et après bon s'ils
ont plus âgés il faut il y a quand même
des on peut pas lire Kant moi je je je
c'est trop compliqué Kant mais je trouve
que les les vidéos les audios de Ferri
sont très bons Luc Ferry il a fait un
travail de fond sur la philo il faut
lire si on peut lire comprendre ce qui
Spinoza comprendre ce que dit Kant mais
à travers des à travers des audios parce
que les bouquins sont habitables j'éis
capable de lire Xavier Fontanel merci
voilà très bien
[Musique]